[Music]
Rob
OT
foreign
house adjourned from the session of
March 16 2023. you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed Nate the eyes have it
house will attend to a Prayer by house
chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart pastor of
Saint Paul's United Methodist Church in
Manchester
oh Spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on this body of the House of
Representatives
As We Gather to discuss the business
that has been presented before us this
day
o Spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on us
melt us
moldus
fill us
ers
to be your hands and feet in this world
guide us today as we make decisions for
all the people of this great state of
New Hampshire
those that have put their trust in US
may you guide and lead us with your
wisdom
o Spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on all the leaders of this
house from each party represented
I pray o god of love that you keep your
loving and guiding hand upon each one
and help them to be effective leaders
o Spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on us
so that we can listen and hear each
other
may we be respectful of each other when
we
speak
oh God melt us
mold us
fill us
and use us to glorify you through the
work we do today
and every day
in Psalm 33
verses 20 through 22 we hear these words
we put our hope in the Lord
God is our help and our Shield
in him our hearts rejoice
for We Trust In His holy name
Let Your unfailing Love surround us Lord
for Our Hope
is in you alone
or Spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on us
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
Farmington representative James Horgan
who will lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
the chair recognized the member from New
Market representative Michael cahu will
[Music]
thank you
the house will attend to request for
leads of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Bartlett Guthrie hatch
lewicki McCarter stavis the day
important business Representatives
Crawford William Dolan meniere and
verville the day illness in the family
disease of actions shall be Grant unless
will attend the introduction of guests
Mr Speaker please welcome Kayla Hubble
guest of Representative yokella former
sergeant-at-arms Deborah Nielsen guest
of Representative shewitt and Bob Perry
guest of Representative Howard they are
with us in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will now attend the consent
calendar
H.R 14 ordered by the speaker from the
committee on Commerce and consumer
affairs House Bill 648 removed by
Representatives Horrigan Tom mannion
Ellen Reed wheeler Gerhard Santa
nastasso sellers Burnham Heinz and Diane
Kelly from the committee on Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs House Bill
277 removed by Representatives Ellen
Reed speline Tom Manion Pines Gerhard
wheeler Diane Kelly papavichi Mueller
Burnham and Santa nastasso
any other bills removed from consent
calendar
representative Robert's moonsack consent
calendar in the relevant amendments is
printed in today's health record be
adopted are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye Metropolis
nay the eyes have it consent calendar
for what what reason to memorize to make
a motion say your motion it's a special
order Bill 189 the first order of
business
is recognized they remember is
would like to special water house bill
and is recognized to speak thank you Mr
Speaker and thank you esteem colleagues
I'm special in this bill bill to first
order business because we have the
family of the fallen soldier in the
gallery so if you could please vote Yes
on this to show our respects to the
fallen soldier I greatly appreciate it
the question before us is the special
water house bill 189 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
as opposed May
the eyes have it
Committee on Public Works in Iowa state
which was referred House Bill 189 in
Akron renaming a portion of Route 140 in
gilmington on a private first class
necklace according to Young having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Sue Newman for
the committee
which I recognize your representative
trottier
speaker
good morning my honorable colleagues
today I Rise before you in support of
House Bill 189
in hopes of renaming a portion of Route
140 in the town of Gilmanton in honor of
private first class Nicholas canoya
Nicholas canoya was born in Concord New
Hampshire and raised in the town of
Gilmanton
he was a graduate of the Guilford High
School class of 2000.
private first class kanoia enlisted in
the U.S army and trained in Fort
Bennington Georgia to serve in the
private first class kenoya was assigned
to deploy to Iraq with the second
Battalion 22nd infantry first brigade
combat team
which is part of the 10th Mountain
division out of Fort Drum New York
on May 18 2006 private first class
kanoi made the ultimate sacrifice while
serving his country and the people of
New Hampshire and right Iraq
during the time of War Act of War
private kanoia died in Baghdad Iraq from
injuries he sustained when it improvised
explosive device detonated next to his
Humvee during active combat operations
I feel it is Our obligation to honor
this New Hampshire hero his family and
his community by renaming a portion of
Route 140 in the town of Gilmanton in
memory of of
private first class canoias for his
service and ultimate sacrifice
he made fighting for our freedom
I ask that each and every one of you
press the green button
and pass this bill to allow his legacy
to live on in his community in the great
state of New Hampshire
Mr Speaker
I asked for a roll call vote
a roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is ought to pass in
house bill 189.
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative new one
Mr Speaker good morning colleagues
it's good to see you all here and up in
the gallery
Mr Speaker
if I know that house bill 189
had the unanimous support of the public
works and highways committee
and that the select board in the town of
Gilmanton wrote that naming this highway
section
is appropriate for private first class
Nicholas cornoyer and will leave a
lasting and visual memory of his
would you please all press the green
button and vote
ought to pass on this Bill thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 189 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
[Applause]
in a very rare occurrence we have a
unanimous vote
or a reason to memorize make a motion Mr
Speaker stage of motion I moved the
remarks from the previous debate be
entered into the permanent journal
for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I wish to make a
motion stage of motion I wish to special
order hb96 the old man on the mountain
you may speak to your motions
thank you Mr Speaker I wish to bring
hb96 before the entire house
for its vote
it's very important because there are
many many people that have contacted me
supporting this bill
not only present residents of New
Hampshire but former residents of New
Hampshire and they wish to know when is
this bill being heard so that they can
either be in the gallery or watch this
online
uh folks from all over the United States
who were residents
would just like to see us in action and
hopefully doing the right thing to bring
this to the floor so that all 400 of us
can vote on this
I appreciate your vote and hope you
would vote green to bring this bill up
so that we can talk about it and vote on
it thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is special order
House Bill 96. are you ready for the
question
the roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
vote
foreign
house bill 96.
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your opposed you'll press a
red button voting stations are open for
members president had an opportunity to
353 voting a 26 voting a special order
passes
majority in the committee on Executive
Apartments Administration to which those
deferred House Bill 96 and acts
recognizing May 3rd as old men of the
mountain day having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpening
to legislate them Chris true for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority of report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass from Diane short for the minority
chair recognize representative Tim
Cahill
thank you Mr Speaker
honored colleagues
special guests
and the citizens of New Hampshire
on May 3rd 2023 it will Mark the 20th
year since the old man and the mountain
collapsed
I remember getting the news from home
Grandma grant called us
to tell us the news
it was a sad day
I remember making the journey to see the
old man when I was a kid
my father took me there
nothing is more Granite State
reading about a father and son team that
worked to keep the old man together was
an inspiring story when I was younger
they climbed out on the rocks and Ledges
working to keep the old man in the
mountain together
so that everyone could enjoy him
that was inspiring
for years David Nielsen and his father
worked to preserve the old man every
year
risking their lives so that the New
Hampshire would still have its mascot
The Old Man of the Mountain
so we the people could still have our
iconic symbol
they embody the best of the Granite
State Live Free or Die
when the old man fell
then Governor Benson was right when he
said
the old man falling was akin to the Twin
Towers
for many of the Granite State and around
the world
I was in DC on September 11th
soon after that I made up my mind that I
wanted to come back home to New
Hampshire
and today I am standing in these honor
chambers before all of you
standing for the people
so what do we do now
this is what we do now
what an amazing way we can promote and
remember Granite State's iconic mascot
whose likeness appears everywhere and on
everything in New Hampshire
from our money our t-shirts our bumper
stickers our signs and our license
plates the old man is everywhere the old
man is New Hampshire
this is the answer to Benson's question
this is what we do now
I ask you to vote ought to pass on HB 96
and join me in honoring the Old Man of
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the old man in the mountain
is the iconic symbol of New Hampshire
it was featured on a three cent stamp
back in the 1950s I have a collection of
them because my dad was a stamp
collector
and there is a plate block of that same
stamp down in the visitor center for
those of you who might want to look at
it
it's also on the 2000
quarter
sponsored by a good friend HCR
13 in 1999
a resolution urging the selection of a
final design of the New Hampshire
commemorative quarter which includes the
state motto Live Free or Die Nine Stars
representing New Hampshire as the ninth
state to ratify the Constitution
and the Old Man of the Mountain
had this bill not pass this body
the Federal Reserve would have put on
the New Hampshire quarter whatever they
this bill
I believe
is needed
because
I propose this bill
I thought about it for about two years I
talked to a bunch of people
and I selected four people to co-sponsor
this bill
representative shurtliff the former
speaker
Jeb Bradley excuse me
two people from the other side of the
wall who are in leadership on both sides
of the aisle
they agreed that it was about time that
somebody recognized the Old Man of the
Mountain
and I've talked to so many people I've
gotten so many emails
I've talked to constituents in Derry
Londonderry Wyndham wherever I visit to
do whatever I need to do
and they all said it's about time
we've let this sit for 20 years
and I believe that the 20th anniversary
should be a commemorative year
the bill itself I don't know if you've
read it
but the bill States
Old Man of the Mountain day the governor
shall issue an annual Proclamation
calling for the proper observance of May
3rd As Old Man of the Mountain day in
honor of the day the iconic rock
formation collapsed
it doesn't ask you to do anything
it doesn't require you to do anything
it's just a day of remembrance
sometime during the day
stop and reflect on what the old man
so
I'm asking you to vote no
on itl
so thank you
my colleagues and thank you Mr Speaker
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker owning a
cabin in the White Mountains there are
some days that I feel like the Old Man
of the Mountain
um Mr Speaker I understand the
committee's vote on this in Italy at
every session they get bills to
recognize uh distinguished people from
the granite state with a permanent day
but this bill is somewhat unique
in so far we're not talking about a
person we're talking about a symbol
and that is not just my opinion that the
old man is assembled in 1945 legislators
sitting in this Hall voted
to name The Old Man of the Mountain the
official symbol of the Granite State and
that's why today we still see the
profile of the old man on Department of
Transportation signs
I know we got a long day so I'm going to
cut this shot I'm not going to talk
about Nathaniel Hawthorne's wonderful
book
The Great Stone phrase I'm not going to
talk about Daniel Webster's outstanding
quote about what the man on the mountain
stands for in that symbolism
let me tell you a story instead now the
Old Man of the Mountain is recognized by
both the Abenaki Indians in the Mohawk
Indians with great reverence
and there's a story in Abernathy law or
about a great Chief named premature
wassid and he fell in love with a
beautiful Native American Woman by the
name of Manawa whose father was the
chief of the Mohawk Tribe they married
and because of that Union for years
there was peace between
the warring Mohawks in the abenakis
one day menowa got a message from her
father saying I'm dying of an illness
going to the Village please come and see
me
before I die
and she told premature was that I will
return just as quickly as I can
and chief Pember johas had told her
every night that you're gone on top of
what is now Canon Mountain I will light
a bonfire
so that when you return to our village
if you do so at the night in the night
time you'll be able to find your way
back to me
and every night Chief image Owasso
climbed cannon in lit that bonfire for
his wife menewa
one night his brother approached him
climbed the mountain said
I've got bad news we have just learned
that your wife died of the same disease
that killed her father
and as the brother started down the
trail from Canon he turned around to see
a temperature was it was following him
and where there had been a bonfire
there was now a great Stone Face the old
man on the mountain
the great spirit turned pimaja wasset
into the old man and had him facing
towards the trail that meant a while
would come back when she returned to
premature Lawson
you know on May 3rd when I heard of 19
in 2003 that the old man had fallen
I thought back to that story I had heard
years ago and I wondered does this mean
the middlewa
in premature was that were finally
United
The Old Man of the Mountain is a very
iconic representation of the Granite
State
it's important
and I asked you to overturn the itl so
another motion could be made
I would like to see a permanent day
dedicated to the old man on the mountain
so the future Generations will stop and
pause and think what the great Stone
Face Metro State not just to the early
settlers but to our Native American
population so I would ask you to please
vote red on the itl so another motion
could be made thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the committee found House
Bill 96 inexpedient to legislate
because we do not believe that putting a
day into statute
is the proper way to memorialize any day
including the Old Man of the Mountain
this year is the 20th anniversary of the
day the Old Man of the Mountain came
mumbling down the mountain
placed in the day in statute will not
memorialize the day
what will memorialize the day is the
famous Granite face of the famous
Granite face is that New Hampshire
citizens will choose to gather
and to celebrate and to honor the
tradition
in closing
please allow me to quote from one of the
greatest British Bohemian disco bands
of all time
Queen
yes that Granite face was sadly caught
in a landslide
I am asking you to press the green
button to support the committee report
of itl
because I do not believe we need that
New Hampshire we need a statute in the
irsas to remind us when to celebrate
and I remind everyone that without there
being a statute in New Hampshire law
for anyone who wishes to keep alive the
remembrance and the history of that
iconic rock face please attend the 20th
anniversary this May 3rd at profile
Plaza and flaconia
commemorating the memory of the Old Man
of the Mountain thank you very much Mr
Speaker
a division has been requested members
the motion before us is majority
committed a report of in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 96. this is a
division vote
the chair recognized representative
as a longtime member of Edna a committee
which is predisposed to deny codifying
every person day or Critter that is
brought to the legislature I usually
agree with that philosophy
but if I know a bipartisan minority of
our committee including myself believes
that this bill should be the exception
to that standard
and if I know that certain dates like
December 7th or 9 11 are dates that
stand out in our national history
and believe in acting this bill would be
the surest way to ensure that May 3rd
will be remembered by Future Generations
in our state as the date we lost our
most famous icon
what I then don't know on this itl
motion so that another motion may be
brought forward thank you
I recognize representative goalie for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know the Edna committee heard numerous
bills already this year on naming days
and had those in in
itl those bills so that with the surmise
that those individuals who came forward
reach out to the governor for their
cause on a yearly basis to keep it going
and if I know just putting into statute
where it'll be with the other 28 days
that
I couldn't read off the top of my head
then
as a matter of fairness to those
organizations that we have said in this
body has said no to in naming days
would I do the same
and support the committee report of
inexpedient to legislative thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of an expedient to
legislate in house bill 96. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposal
press the red button Pony stations are
all members president had an opportunity
181 voting yay 198 voting a motion of
index we need to legislate fails for
what reason to memorize
thank you Mr Speaker I moved the
question and asked the body to vote
ought to pass thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us now was ought to
pass are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and they ought to pass
motion passes Mr Speaker
what was memorized like to make a motion
State commotion uh move the thief
remarks from the previous debate be
all those in favor of printing their
remarks in a permanent Journal say aye
those opposed me
and I haven't and the remarks will be
printed
four reason to memorize uh Mr Speaker I
Rise to make a motion stage of motion uh
I would move that we special order House
Bill 49 until first thing tomorrow
morning that the people who helped build
that uh that bill over the last two
years are planning to be here first
thing tomorrow morning and are traveling
a great distance and would like to be
here for the debate
motion before us is the special water
house bill 49 till tomorrow morning the
a division
a division has been requested members
the motion before us is the special
water house bill 49.
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your pulse you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
well members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
226 voting yay 153 voting a the motion
fails did not
come to the three-fifth president in
voting
the committee on children and family law
to which was referred house bill
House Bill 10 FN establishing the
Mark Pearson moves ought to Bass and
Representative Bob Lin moves Amendment
floor Amendment 1146 h
chair recognized representative Raymond
good morning thank you for your patience
with me as I hobbled down the hallway I
rise in opposition to this amendment to
house bill 10. this is an eight-page
amendment to a six-page bill that makes
significant changes to hb10 and seeks to
change both the definition of and
current burden of proof for child abuse
and neglect in New Hampshire this body
has consistently affirmed that any
changes to the child abuse and neglect
statutes and mandated reporter
requirements
ought to be made only in the best
interest of our children
the Amendment states that school
personnel and all other government
entities including dcyf
only have a compelling interest to
protect children if there is clear and
convincing evidence of physical abuse or
neglect this is an unworkable new
standard that rewrites the existing
Child Protection Law to make it more
difficult for dcyf to protect children
this legislature has always honored
parental rights in fact the bill
contains the parental rights statues
that were passed into law in 2018.
The Helpful Folks at the New Hampshire
Department of Education already
collected the entire list of Rights and
put them into an easy to reach and easy
to understand memo back in August 2022
this bill and this amendment
requires teachers school resource
officers guidance counselors and other
staff working in schools to monitor kids
generator gender identity and expression
and then report that information to
parents further this amendment includes
an unfunded government mandate for
schools to create a new database to
track and report on what clubs students
attend despite the fact that schools
currently do not track this information
and many high school clubs are run by
students on a drop-in basis
teachers who would rather not insert
themselves in kids personal lives would
face criminal penalties for recommending
to parents that they should talk to
their own child about these private
family matters
aside from the Constitutional issues
that targeting a marginalized group for
increased government surveillance
presents these Provisions also represent
a massive government overreach to
teachers should focus on educating and
not being forced into the middle of
disagreements between parents and kids
over pronouns they certainly should not
be facing criminal penalties and the
loss of teaching credentials for
sticking to their areas of expertise and
referring families to community resource
resources for personal family issues
lastly the office of the child advocate
and Community agencies that provide
support to Granite State children and
their families including Nami New
Hampshire Waypoint the ACLU glad
Seacoast Outreach and several pastors
and church leaders
overwhelmingly testified in opposition
to this bill at the child and family law
committee
people who care about children have been
clear the parents rights that are
already in state law are appropriate
this amendment does not add nor codify
natural rights instead it redefines
child abuse and neglect and creates a
pathway for abusive parents to exploit
individuals in schools to further
control children's behaviors and
identities placing lgbtq plus children
at greater risk of harm please join us
in standing up for the best interests of
children in New Hampshire by pressing
the red button on OTP so a more
appropriate motion can be made
thank you
the house will be in order
pardon me the chair represents
recognizes representative Paul Terry to
speak to the ought to pass motion on
uh thank you madam speaker
Pro tem deputy
honored colleagues and guests
the latest version of hb10 a parental
Bill of Rights for the citizens of New
Hampshire has been finalized
as floor Amendment 1146 h
it is the product of countless hours of
research consultation listening
discussion and changes
that have been made for a bill
and it's for a bill which identifies and
secures certain fundamental and vitally
important natural and inalienable rights
parents have for the bringing up of
their children with special focus on
education and Medical Care
these natural rights are also historic
rights that have been acknowledged for
centuries across many cultures in the
world around
however more recently they have come
under grave threat in our country
hence the need to address and correct
imbalances that have become all too
imbalances that are not only the result
of mistakes or oversights but also a
growing and serious misunderstanding of
the two most significant trusts that
exists between parents on the one hand
and their trustees Educators and medical
care providers on the other
hb10 with this amendment not only
enumerates certain parental rights but
serves to inform and assist Educators in
medical care providers
as to their responsibilities towards the
parents whose children have been
entrusted to them for particular
purposes
hb10 with this amendment makes clear
what natural law recognizes in our
nation's courts
have a firm time and time again
absent extraordinary circumstances
the natural order of Life prescribes
that parents must be recognized and
respected in the raising of their
children
the health vitality and future of our
state nation and Any Nation depend upon
how well we honor and advance
this essential tenet
so therefore absent any compelling State
interest the right of parents to
determine the educations in health care
of their children is primary
this means parents have a right to know
what their children are being taught how
they are conducting themselves when at
school and the ways they are being
treated by ones who stand in a de facto
and professionally determined
relationship of what is both an implied
and an expressed Trust
in an earlier time there was a general
consensus as to the role of Educators in
medical care providers
but nowadays this consensus is fractured
hb10 with this amendment has been made
necessary
by the teaching of curricula and
practices that far too many professional
Educators wrongly believe is protected
against parental inquiry
the assertion and practice of such a
presumptive belief has no basis in
nature or natural law
therefore it cannot be permitted to go
unaddressed by the law
hb10 with this amendment is reasonable
carefully measured
and prudent
it recognizes and safeguards against
potential misuse of any of the rights it
contains
not one person who supports this bill
wants for any parent child and family to
be anything other than helped by its
provisions
and that is exactly what it will
accomplish
HP 10 with this amendment is not a
weapon to divide but a tool to unite
a tool for parents Educators and Health
Care practitioners to more effectively
care for the children to which each
respectively and specifically has been
entrusted
out there
Beyond this hallowed Hall the people of
New Hampshire are asking and expecting
that we will hear their voices and
respond to their desire for a parental
Bill of Rights
how many people
nearly 80 percent according to the most
recent Statewide poll on this question
80 percent
that's not just a majority that's a
veritable Avalanche a landslide
so let's make sure we deliver for them
because if we deliver for them
I urge you to vote OTP on the floor
Amendment 1146h and then again on hb10
also vegan order the chair recognizes
thank you madam speaker I should say
that I had not intended to speak on this
uh Amendment but I do I do rise to speak
and I strongly support it and I think it
was the one thing that I want to focus
on is the suggestion that somehow
adopting this amendment
um uh would would permit uh would change
the law with respect to uh the abuse and
neglect it does not do that in any way
the definition of compelling State
interest that is contained in this
amendment is limited to the is limited
to this bill and the rights that are
created in this bill and the rights that
are created in this bill are our rights
to know not rights to abuse if a parent
is Abu has abused a child there's
nothing in this amendment or this bill
proposes to change that so let me just
take let me just take one give you one
specific example which I think kind of
gets at the heart of what people who
oppose this are concerned about
let's suppose because then this arises
in the transgender example let's suppose
that a child has made a disclosure to a
parent to a teacher that he or she is
transitioning and instead of using the
name Sam which is the given name of the
child the child now wants to be referred
to as Sue
this amendment says that the the the
school cannot keep that information from
the parent even if the child says
something like
my you know if I tell my if I tell my
father he'll kill me well if that's if
that's what the child says the school
certainly has an obligation to go
further than that and find out is the
child really saying my parent will kill
me he really means that and that's what
he's talking about or is the child just
saying you know if I tell my parent he's
going to be very disappointed and angry
and upset with me which would not be
enough to disclose to fail to disclose
to the parent because it's we're not we
don't I submit to you we should not be
protecting children from the ordinary
things in life the ordinary human
emotions that parents Express from time
to time life is hard sometimes but that
doesn't mean that parents should be able
that schools should be able to keep
information from their parents this
amendment specifically says that if it's
more than If there really is a serious
threat to the child either either
physically or even psychologically then
the state and the school district in my
example certainly has to do something
they can and there are they are it's
specifically authorized by this to go to
the appropriate authorities to pursue
abuse and neglect proceedings but what
this says this says that the state
cannot do or the school district cannot
do in my example is they can't simply
say
we're very very concerned that there
could actually be some abuse here so
what are we going to do about it well
the only thing we're going to do about
it is not tell the parents we're not
going to do anything else now stop and
think about that for a minute what is
the likelihood that if the school
actually took that tact that that would
be effective is it really the case that
where the teacher in my example that the
school has told the teacher
um I mean sorry the student has told the
teacher you know I'm transitioning and
I'm using the names I want to use the
name Sue is it really likely that nobody
else except the teacher knows that very
unlikely some other students some of the
people in the school know that and what
happens if there really is a threat to
the child if the parent finds out if the
only thing the school does is not tell
the parent what do you think is going to
happen if somehow it gets back to the
parent from another from another uh
Source the school's going to say oh we
we we satisfied our responsibility we
just we didn't tell the parents so we're
off the hook of course that shouldn't be
the law and this doesn't allow it to be
the law what it says is schools if you
have a real basis to believe that
there's a threat to a child then you yes
of course you can take action and maybe
part of that action is you don't tell
the parents but you have to do more you
have to actually take some action and if
you're not willing to do that if all you
want to do is just not tell the parents
that strongly suggests that that you're
not really concerned with the welfare of
the child and you're just trying to
avoid the child having to have a
difficult conversation with a parent and
I submit to you respectfully that should
the house will be in order the question
before the house is the ought to pass
motion on floor Amendment 1146 H are you
ready for the question division was
called this will be a division votes
the chair recognizes representative
thank you chair
if I know that the responsibility of
lawmakers is to first and foremost
prioritize the collective well-being of
granite Staters in their decision making
and if I know that our transgender and
gender questioning youth have the same
right to safety and privacy as any other
student and if I know that this bill
would mandate autocratic surveillance of
students as well as the outing of
transgender students regardless of the
known or unknown family Dynamics
and if I know that child abuse including
the known incitement of psychological
and emotional harm are serious offenses
that produce an unnecessary threat to
the well-being of our children then I
would now compel you to vote no on the
amendment before us thank you
the chair recognizes representative Lynn
thank you thank you madam speaker if I
know that this bill represents a
carefully balanced approach that is
designed that draws an appropriate
protection for children against abuse
and also preserves parental rights and
enhances parental rights and if I know
that the that much of the opposition to
this bill is based on the theory that
parents can't be trusted that school
officials know better or the government
knows better than than parents what's in
their best interest and that of why and
if I know that while of course there
needs to be safeguards to protect to
protect children uh from from the very
very few parents who may be abusive or
neglectful uh this bill contains those
protections then what I press the green
button to support this amendment thank
you madam speaker
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on floor Amendment 1146 h on
House Bill 10. this is a division vote
if you are in favor you'll press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
the house will tend to the state of the
vote oh pardon me have all members who
were present when the question was voted
the house will attend to the state of
with 190 members voting the affirmative
109 voting 194 voting in the negative
the motion before us now is ought to
pass on House Bill 10 the house will be
thank you
thank you madam speaker
I stand before this body today as a
fellow Granite stator
fellow parent
and for some a fellow Survivor of
domestic violence
I stand in opposition to hb10
for those of us that have walked in
these shoes we know how domestic
violence can fester and thrive in the
secrecy of our homes how even the
smallest upset can lead to holes in the
walls bruises and a tirade of verbal
insults
for many of us we share this reality
with children
children that don't know any different
this is the only life that they know
as a matter of fact in 2020 according to
the National Children's Alliance 618
000 children were victims of abuse in
the United States
77 percent of those were abused by their
parents
as many as 10 million children in the
U.S are witness to abuse between parents
and caregivers in their home each year
are all parents abusive absolutely not
and many of them enjoy open dialogue and
communication with their children
in the children and family law committee
we had a very brave Survivor testify
here's a small portion of her testimony
while some parents are good and
trustworthy I know firsthand the damage
a parent can inflict as a Survivor I
know the importance of being able to
have trusted teachers and faculty at
schools teachers and counselors are
required to go to school and get to
Greece to teach and advise kids
but anyone can be a parent no degree or
class is required
she is only 16 and she is my daughter
her journey is one that I know but even
for what I know part of it that I do not
know is hers to tell when she's ready
I was fortunate when our walls Came
Crashing Down to have teachers that each
of my children could talk to it was a
brutal and scary moment in life the
authorities even telling us that he was
most likely going to come after me and
kill me
I had a lifetime protection order for
myself
but for the kids that was still a
process of going through a parental
rights evaluator waiting for findings
as the kids started to realize that this
wasn't how everyone lived they shared
with their trusted teachers parts of
what they had lived through
was their biological father asking what
was happening in school what was going
on with the kids absolutely that was his
right as a father
I could only imagine his struggle with
this since he had been in full control
of Our Lives for over 16 years
however as the authorities were
investigating the teachers did not
divulge details to him understanding the
dangers involved if they did he had
after all told each of the kids if they
told anyone he would finish the job of
strangling their brother
if a bill like hb10 had been in place
they would have been compelled to tell
him
you might be wondering about that
protection order I had that should be
keeping him far enough away from them to
keep them safe since they were with me
most of the time
when I turned on my car multiple times
the Bluetooth would say connecting to
Joseph's iPhone he was within a hundred
feet of us
our story and my kids are not anomalies
so many kids are suffering abuse and the
only chance they have for respite and a
sense of peace is when they go to school
in that safe place hopefully they have a
chance to tell a teacher what's
happening at home and this part is so
important even still many kiddos have
practiced tells with something more
benign before they divulge information
that could be life or death for them
just to see if they are safe to see if
what they say gets back to their parents
hb10 will absolutely take away their
safe place and as the education
commissioner put into place the one
trusted adult program
and if you're thinking that the
following part of the bill
makes this um
covers this part for this reality from
too many children because it says does
not authorize a parent of a minor child
to engage in conduct that is unlawful or
to abuse or neglect his or her minor
child in violation of the law I beg you
to remember that this is already against
the law and children are still being
abused daily please vote against this
dangerous and damaging bill as my
daughter so eloquently said not all
homes are like ours was but some are and
the chair recognizes representative
Terry
representative Terry is waving off
the chair recognizes representative
petrigno
thank you madam chair
excuse me Madam speaker my apologies
I rise in opposition to house bill 10.
recognizing fully that the deepest human
bond is between parents and their
children
and that parents have an inalienable
right to direct the upbringing of their
children and that those rights are well
rooted in common law
yet there are questions and
considerations which put this
legislation in doubt
it should be noted that the vast
majority of Educators and school board
members are parents too
do we seriously believe that they would
promote school policies that would deny
them their rights as parents
I wonder if some parents will feel
emboldened to take on schools for
anything they believe to be improper
will this result in a barrage of
frivolous lawsuits that school districts
will have to defend at tax payers
expense
but the greatest points here is that
this legislation is not necessary
simply because the rights enumerated
already exist in federal and state
statutes
the department of education's directives
and School Board policies
in fact at the beginning of this school
year the Department of Education
released the technical advisory to
parents listening all of the rights
which are now restated in this bill
it's almost as if the sponsors cut and
paste this bill together
from the Department of education's
website
more so in committee
the sponsors themselves admitted that
parental rights already exist
and I quote
Beyond this point the focus in committee
was on provisions
which require teachers to respond to
parents inquiries upon requests
the sponsor is no full well that this is
not a natural right
and arguably unconstitutional
it would be the equivalent of telling
someone
that their life is threatened if they do
not tell you what they want to know
that's not a right
that's coercion
in this case it would mean that teachers
would lose their jobs and face civil in
criminal liability
this is not a matter of keeping secrets
no responsible adult keeps inappropriate
secrets with children
this is a this is a matter of teachers
not betraying students confidentiality
as trusted adults
I was a teacher for 40 years
as a teacher ask me about your child's
academic performance
and their school conduct and I will be
happy to answer
ask me about concerns regarding your
child's gender identity and I will tell
you you need to go home and talk
to your child
as a trusted adult I will not violate
students confidentiality
and no one
is going to force me to go against my
it seems to me that none of this
was ever an issue until recently
but now that students who identify as
lgbtq Plus
are no longer willing to remain in the
closet it appears that some parents are
now demanding to know
are we trying to legislate to account
for the lack of openness that some
children have with their parents
for whatever reason
probably the most compelling testimonial
committee came from the New Hampshire's
child advocate who testified in our
committee that there are children who
are abused when they have disclosed
their gender identity to their families
and that her office sees such cases on a
daily basis
threatening action against trusted
adults put all vulnerable children not
just those of the LGBT community In
it was only this past summer
that the governor created a unique
partnership between the Department of
Education and the one trusted adult
program
in doing so the one trusted adult
founder said
when a student can name a trusted adult
at school we create our best chance for
preventing bullying
mental health issues and substance abuse
all while promoting positive self-worth
engagement in community and availability
for learning
pass this law
and you are putting every child who
struggles with something at risk
pass this and you are telling the
governor to say goodbye to his one
trusted adult program
yes we can all agree that parents have
the right to direct the education of
their children but never to the
detriment of the rights of other parents
or which compromise the safety of all
children
more than codifying a negligible list of
parental rights the real Focus to
promote the well-being of children
must be on Parental Partnerships with
schools to promote values in Civic
virtues in our diverse Society
and to foster a learning environment
where all of our students can Thrive
house will be in order
chair recognizes rep resentative Steven
Smith
thank you madam speaker
I rise today in support of New Hampshire
parents families and the children
families are ugly right the messy they
can be I mean mine wasn't Norman
Rockwell for sure both with my parents
and then as a parent with my kids
but you get through it it can be
ugly hurtful
and always worth it because your family
right they're the people that will be
there for you to back you up even if
they don't like you
which was a good thing in my family so
in one example of my parental failings
uh one of my sons we did not get along
there had been a long history of my
ex-wife and I not making things go
particularly well in the households
using tools against each other and this
particular child while he was a rebel
and strong
headed and willful no idea where he got
that could not possibly be genetic
we did probably everything we could to
go at each other for a while and then he
became an adult and we didn't speak for
years
until one day he found himself in a
particularly difficult situation in his
no matter what we did to each other he
knew that in his darkest moment I would
be the one that would back him up
give parents a little credit we we
explode on things but we still love our
kids we may not even like our kids
but we still love our kids and will do
anything for them
so
do you think it's harder for the kid
that's in a difficult situation to just
deal with what they're going through or
to think they have to hide it from their
parents and my household that meant
there were going to be two difficult
conversations the one where I'm asking
why did I have to find this out from
somebody else and then you get to the
important one and you know that first
one it's it's a waste of time but it's
going to happen why did your child not
confide in you
when whenever that happens and it was
rare I would try to figure out what I
had done to make them feel like they
couldn't confide in me we should be
encouraging those conversations not
discouraging them by telling the kids
you know we're not going to tell your
parents about this that's that's not
helpful
and these days of rising depression
feelings of suicide among young people
let me ask you do you think it helps or
hurts to tell them that they shouldn't
go home and talk to their parents about
this
do you think it helps or hurts that they
are made to feel like they have to keep
this thing a secret do you think that
makes them less depressed or more
depressed
I think it's more depressed but I'm not
a psychologist I ask you to find that
when parents lose their rights right now
for whatever transgression they've done
there was a long strenuous process to go
through to make that happen
and that's right because taking
someone's parental rights away should be
a really big deal shouldn't it
yeah
if I was a school employee do you think
that I should decide what you know about
your kids or do you think you should
know that
that's really the Crux of the matter
here I think parents have a right to
know everything about their kids they're
their kids they're ultimately
responsible for them for their emotional
development
for their financial responsibilities we
are responsible for our children I do
not want somebody sitting in an office
somewhere or even a classroom to decide
all by themselves you know what Steve
doesn't get to know this about his kids
that's wrong
on a bigger level I'm not sure that it's
a school's place to be involved in that
type of development but if they are
because that horse seems to have left
the barn then let them be all in let
them go all the way let them talk to the
kids and say that's going to be really
hard but you got to talk to your family
about this and support those
conversations and even facilitate those
conversations not keep them a secret to
connect the children with the resources
that exist to support them as they go
through what could be a difficult time
and even the kids that will be surprised
when they go home and find out the
conversation wasn't as bad as they
thought because at the end of the day
your family loves you thank you madam
speaker
wherever the house will be a order
representative Doucette request a roll
this is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members will please
the chair recognizes representative long
thank you madam speaker
if I know has testified to by the office
of child advocate that this bill will
hurt you
and if I further know that the seven or
eight years of parties that have
adjustment to Children and Family laws
this bill will set us back on those
initiatives that we've already created
and if I further know
that the solutions that we're attempting
to resolve on this bill
will not resolve the issues that will
still get to hear from the same parents
then would I press the red button thank
you madam speaker
the chair recognizes representative
if I want to attack the inherent rights
of parents
to be a hundred percent involved in your
daily lives
and if I know this bill results in
common sense legislation that confirms
parents
not the government direct the upbringing
Education and Care of their minor
children
and if I know in recent polls
more than one thousand New Hampshire
voters
when asked about keeping secrets 78
percent or better supported a parent's
right to know
if I also know that parents should be
able to ask School personnel
direct questions about their own
children
and what is happening to them in school
because they pay taxes for full
transparency not secrets
and finally if I know that our
children's future is on the line in that
I along with many others believe that
parents make the best choices for their
families will they now support and Trust
the very Foundation that these children
depend on their parents by pressing the
green button
the question is
motion on House Bill 10. this is a roll
call vote if you are in favor you'll
press the green button if you are
opposed you'll press the red button
services
foreign
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
with 189 vote members voting in the
affirmative and 195 voting in the
this will be a division vote members
will take their seats
this will be a division votes members
are there in the seats we'll take their
seats
the motion before us to delay House Bill
10 on the table the chair recognizes
representing hole for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you madam speaker
if I know that children matter
if I know as a father the best thing you
can do with your life also the hardest
thing you can do with your life
is cherish your children
if I know that we that the committee
worked on an amendment that was not
discussed on the floor that's in this
week's calendar that was not brought up
what I now vote Yes on a table motion
if I know that responsible professionals
teachers counselors and others
always work
with youth
to find ways of reconnecting them with
their family and preserving the family
bond
cause that is
the most important thing in a child's
life
but if I know that passage of this law
will put many kids who cannot do that in
safety
at risk
and if I want the opportunity to put
this well-meaning but very harmful
Bill to rest what I wrote no on the
tabling motion so we can return to itl
thank you
question is on the motion of laying
House Bill 10 on the table this is a
division vote if you are in a favor you
will press the green button if you
opposed you'll press the red button
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
with 193 members voting in the
affirmative at 192 voting in the
negative the motion to lay House Bill 10
on the table
passes and I will the speaker did vote
well we'll definitely have her back up
here again
majority committee on children family
law to which was referred House Bill 548
FN act relative to definition of
compliance with a legal support order
for a child support payments considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that as
inexpedient to legislate listen to
Heather Raymond the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendations Bill ought to pass
Senator Mark Pearson for minority of the
committee
care recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today to urge the distinguished
body to oppose the itl motion on HB 548
so that an amendment may be offered and
another motion may be made
this bill currently only has one flaw
that of a crossout in the beginning that
was never requested during Drafting and
went unnoticed until the bill was in
committee
it's a very simple bill
and a much needed bill
this bill will set into law a definition
of a threshold of what it means to be in
compliance with child support
currently under the RSA
the Division of Child Support Services
must report any arrearage resulting in
non-compliance
of an order of Child Support to the
federal government
but the RSA does not define any dollar
amount which if exceeded signifies
non-compliance
thus a simple rounding error
that put a person under the request
required payment on any particular week
by as little as one penny
result in reporting to the federal
government and denial of any federal
government services
I experienced this firsthand even though
I pay child support by automatic
theoretically
I should never be able to be in default
because I have no control over the
withdrawal of payments to the state from
imagine my surprise when I tried to
renew my passport in 2022 so that I
could go to Canada for work
and I was denied because the federal
government said I was not current on my
child support payments
how could this happen
like most people these days I am not
paid weekly I am paid bi-weekly
the calculation for payments to the
state is made by taking the court
ordered weekly amount and multiplying it
by 52. then dividing it by 26. this
results in situations where I am
sometimes over the amount due and
sometimes under the amount due
when the federal state department
queried the state to process my passport
they were told I was in arrears
because the state system doesn't tell
the federal government how much your
inner ears
I was told this directly from the state
department when I called
our system here in the state simply
tells them thumbs up or thumbs down
could be a few months or it could be a
penny the federal government's not going
to know
so this bill
will ensure that only a true delinquency
will qualify
and simple rounding errors are not
reported
it sets a threshold of twenty five
dollars
anything under 25 dollars the federal
government doesn't need to be notified
but anything that's over that we can
start to consider that a delinquency in
child support
and report it and
use those leverages that the federal
government can do
please join me in pressing the red
button to overturn the itl
so that a better motion can be made and
so that the amendment can be given with
all it does is restore the crossed
outline when we pass that Amendment
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in support of the committee
recommendation of itl on HB 548
this is a bill that was written in
response to one individual's perception
of why their application for passport
renewal was denied by the federal
government
the committee was told that the password
application was denied due to a rounding
error that made them one cent behind on
child support payments currently federal
laws state that one must be 60 days in
arrears and owe at least five hundred
and fifty dollars before passport and or
driver's license renewals can be frozen
we do not know the private details of
the anecdotal circumstance that led to
the drafting of this bill however we do
know that rounding errors and matters of
pennies do not meet the threshold for
impacting passports and driver's license
this legislation is simply not needed
and is essentially a solution in search
of a problem this bill will impact the
office of Child Support Services by
creating an unfunded mandate to change
how they track and when they report
unpaid child support to the agency's
responsibles for passports and driver's
licenses I urge you to support the
bipartisan committee majority by
pressing the green button on the itl
motion
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpeding to
legislator and House Bill 548 are you
ready for the question
a division has been requested members
ideas
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of nhb the legislator
and House Bill 548 this is a division
vote chair recognizes representative D
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that our colleague
and many others support paying people
who pay their child support via
garnished wages
have been aggrieved by the state of New
Hampshire's error in reporting process
and refused
a passport so that they can do the job
wouldn't I
be frustrated with that
therefore I would press the red button
so that a better motion can be brought
I recognize representative long for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that it takes more than pennies to
uh flag the feds or the state of New
Hampshire with respect to your passports
and driver's license and if I further
know that an agreement between two
parties would remove the garnishment
requirements solving this issue then
would I press green on the itl motion
thank you Mr Speaker the motion reports
majority committee report of index we
need to legislator in hospital 548 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if your
opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
president had an opportunity to vote
189 148 187 voting Noida committee
majority committee on Commerce and
consumer affairs to which was referred
House Bill 584 act relative to the
uniform commercial codes article on
controllable electronic records have
been considered the same report the same
with the following Amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment was in our Keith
Ammon for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislate Senator
Christopher Hebert for the minority of
the committee
the amendment is
0993h printed in housework at 16 page
93. the question is on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
Mr opposed nay
you guys have it amendment is adopted
the question before us is the ought to
pet the motion ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
is
majority on a committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which it
was deferred House Bill 135 FN act
prohibiting no knock warrants having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
to fill out a pass with amendment of
Senator Terry Roy for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
falling resolution that is inexpediate
to legislate Senate of Jonah wheeler for
the minority of the committee
y through 61. we have a debate on the
amendment the chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker the amendment
before you which would is an amendment
to a bill which would ban no knock
warrants from being carried out in our
state it is a simple Amendment which
says in so many words that the practice
of no knock warrants will be left to the
discretion of the police department
carrying out the warrant this would
affirm the common law as it stands right
now into statute
my opposition to doing so is that it
leaves this bill a hollow signal of
virtue
I can recall with more clarity than I
care for when the police barged into my
house when I was butt six seven years
old
a shuddering scream from my mother woke
me from what was a peaceful sleep
I ran downstairs to find
my mother
being yelled at by police officers
demanding that that she could be
arrested
yelling at her friend shoving me to the
side and taking out taking her out of
the house no answers no conversation I
sat there left with an old friend of
hers who was staying the night both of
us in absolute shock
this prompted by someone calling the
police on that friend who had committed
the unforgivable crime of smoking a
cigarette outside of his door not
knowing that there was a rule in the
apartment complex that you had to walk
down to the street to smoke your
cigarette
threatened her life with prison
taking her children away from her luck
was not on her side that day
this was prompted because my mother who
was pulled over a few weeks before just
for the first time in her life may I add
just so happened to have drugs on her
the police arrested her tried to charge
her with possession took her to court
like I said threatened to take away her
child and by the grace of God
we stayed with her for our entire
childhood and those charges were dropped
but I recall this story not to interject
my personal tale into this debate but to
illustrate as someone put it to me the
other day how mundane this experience is
for the majority of people in our state
the police coming into your home
unannounced terrorizing you and your
family being a mundane experience for
most people is truly a sad State of
Affairs
I understand why policing is so critical
and have a great respect for the work
law enforcement does I also understand
the great distrust the People Back Home
are starting to feel about law
enforcement
in many instances policy makers have let
them go too far
we here today have an opportunity to
correct that balance and while we are
not going to quell all of the anger
which exists and then we have an
opportunity to quell some of the anger
which exists in our people by telling
the boot stepping on their neck
it's a step a little less hard and I ask
you to join me in support and voting
against this committee Amendment so that
we can support a bill that actually bans
no knock warrants instead of one which
leaves the practice up to the discretion
of the police department carrying out
the warrant thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this amendment
takes into account
the need while extremely rare to have
this in the toolbox of our law
enforcement
to do away with no knock warrants
totally
puts lives at danger police lives
imagine
you have to serve a search warrant on an
apartment
and inside are five MS-13 members with
machine guns
and you have to knock on the door and
tell them you're there
not a not a good way to enter
imagine you have to search
an apartment
and the person on the other side of the
door
is with his wife and he told her I'm
going to kill you if you ever call the
cops on me
so should they knock on the door and say
hi police
or should they get in there and rescue
that person
now we heard testimony from the New
Hampshire State Police
and from the Manchester State Manchester
police from their special tactics unit
they said these you these type of
warrants are so rare they couldn't even
remember the last time they had to do
one but they begged us please don't take
them away because it can be very
dangerous in certain rare circumstances
to knock on that door and say police
search warrant because that gives the
person on the other side of the door
just enough time to get ready to kill
you
it's easy for us to sit here safe in
this Hall but picture three in the
morning having a kick in a door when you
know people on the other side have
machine guns and they want to kill you
taking that tool away even for rare
circumstances is going to result in
deaths of police officers and that's
wrong
so what did we do with this amendment we
looked at the concerns
and I took it seriously and I said okay
let's see what the federal government
right now under President Biden is doing
he directed his doj to narrow these down
so I took almost verbatim the language
from the Department of Justice on what
they require to use no knock warrants
tailored it for New Hampshire and that
is this amendment
it says
you cannot use no knock warrants to
preserve evidence
it used to be back in the day and maybe
still is that drug dealers would keep
their drugs their fentanyl whatever it
is in the bathroom so when they heard
police they'd go in there dump it flush
it evidence gone that used to be the
basis for a no knock warrant
this prohibits that this amendment
prohibits that the only reason you can
get a new knock warrant now under this
amendment would be to preserve life if
you can articulate to your chief law
enforcement officer that there's a
reason that I fear for my life going in
that door and you have to spell it out
in the case of evidence
it makes one exception and that is if
the evidence is to deal with human life
for example if there's a computer in
there and there's evidence of a pending
terrorist attack
and they can destroy it before they get
in there that would be the only way they
could use it to get evidence
so it's been extremely limited extremely
tailored and in that case mind you they
have to get permission from the attorney
general before they can even get such a
warrant
also the amendment creates the ability
for the public to see what's going on if
you went in to try and get a search
warrant or the results prior to this
you would have a very difficult time
this amendment makes it so that those
search warrant results and the affidavit
behind them become immediately public
so this amendment takes into concerns
that people have about no knock search
warrants they could no longer be used
just to collect and preserve evidence
only to protect the lives of the people
inside like a domestic violence victim
or the officers having to go in there
because they can articulate that there's
something or someone dangerous inside
that house
so I would ask you all close your eyes
take yourself out of this safe reps Hall
put on a uniform and pretend you have to
go through a door on the other side of
our people who have sworn to kill you
but you have to tell them you're there
thank you please support the committee
Amendment
the motion before us
is on the amendment
zero six eight four eight Senator has
requested a roll call and that is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
foreign
committee Amendment 0684h this is a roll
call vote
chair recognized representative Hull for
if I know
that between 2010 and 2016
81 civilians were killed and 13 officers
lost their lives
in no knock warrant raids
if I know that MS-13 routinely doesn't
own machine guns because the
the on books price is 25 000 or more
and probably not within their bank
account
after hearing the story of the mayor
from Berwyn Heights Maryland where the
no knock warrant raid was on the wrong
person
if I know lastly that in speaking with a
House member who's a landlord today that
the tenant that they were going after
had moved out and a new tenant was in
his apartment building and they raided
the wrong family
would I now oppose the committee
Amendment and stop this
and then work on draft crafting a narrow
exemption maybe in the Senate thank you
I recognize the representative Roy for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know the MS-13 probably does not buy
and if I know that everything that was
just spoken about happened in another
state with departments that have 10 15
20 000 members and not here in New
Hampshire
would I then support our law enforcement
and our citizens by making this narrow
exemption and supporting the bipartisan
committee Amendment thank you
the motion before us is committee
Amendment 0684h
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposal press a red button voting
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
299 voting yay 84 voting a the amendment
is adopted we're moving on now to ought
chair recognize his representative
wheeler
representative wheeler waves off
representative Roy weighs off now are
you ready for the question
representative San Andreas requested a
roll call and it is sufficiently
seconded
this will be a roll call vote
members take your seats members should
the motion before us has ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 135 this is a
foreign
House Bill 135 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button learning stations are
[Music]
well members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attends
374 voting a nine voting a committee
for what purpose does it memberize house
will be in order
I Rise to make a motion State your
motion I move free consideration on HB
to be divisions
this will be a division vote
members take your seats
the motion before us is reconsideration
the motion before us is a motion to
reconsider House Bill 548 this is a
division vote
care recognized representative Hobson
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that I
would like to reconsider my vote your if
we should reconsider the vote would you
vote green thank you
chairman
speaker
I can't believe I did that my apologies
it's already been a long day
if I know that
we should all come down on the side of
the children who need support and we got
that right the first time what I now
vote no on reconsideration thank you
the motion before us is the
reconsideration on House Bill 548 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button to be
opposer press the red button voting
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
189 voting a 193 voting a the motion for
reconsideration fails representative
Moulton declared on conflict of entrance
the house will be in order
majority committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was deferred
House Bill 351 FN act relative to the
negligence storage of firearms and
relative to firearm safety devices
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and a
recommendation that the bill ought to
password Amendment president of David
Muse for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being I don't agree
with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpediate to legislate soon Jonathan
okay
the question is on the amendment
0592h printed in house record 16 page
75-76 chair recognizes representative
Roy
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I'll keep this short this
amendment and Bill were considered by
the committee
this
Bill and its Amendment as adopted
would infringe upon the rights of people
to keep firearms in their home and
accessible
to be used
and that's really the bottom line
it doesn't need to be discussed and
debated to death it means that you
wouldn't be able to have your firearm
accessible without being subject to a
penalty
and
that's not what the courts ruled the
courts have ruled that you have to a
firearm inaccessible is not a firearm
for you to use
the Supreme Court said as much now the
Supreme Court has said that reasonable
restrictions as I'm sure you will hear
are authorized but they all specifically
said having a firearm so that you can't
get at it is the same as having none at
all so please
vote the correct way on this and vote
against it thank you
I think you will keep this brief what
the amendment actually does is remove
the part of the bill that requires a
locking safety device accompany all
commercial and Private Sales and
transfers if that's something that you
agree with please vote for the amendment
the committee actually supported the
amendment by a bipartisan 17 to 2 vote
so this does make it a better Bill thank
you
the motion before us
is
Senator cool has requested a roll call
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us the adoption of the
committee Amendment
0592h this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
well members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
184 voting yay 19649 the amendment fails
please hold
is this on just the bill itself
yeah this is um
if I have the rights
keep my firearms in my home however I
feel that I need to keep them in order
to keep my family safe at all times
and if it is illegal already to
what I just
HB 351 is a bill that will have zero
impact on responsible gun owners
that's because responsible gun owners
would never leave an unattended firearm
or ammunition in any place where it
could be accessed by a child
what the bill does is extend and toughen
New Hampshire's existing state policy
and penalties when it comes to
irresponsible gun owners who leave
unattended Firearms where children can
access them
it also requires that all firearms
commercially sold or transferred be
accompanied by a locking safety device
currently our state has no laws
regarding safe firearm storage we do
have an existing law that addresses
Firearms negligence in children but that
law is extremely weak
under the current law if a child finds
an unsecured firearm and takes it to a
school a playground or to a neighbor's
house where they play with it with other
children the owner of the gun can't be
charged
that's because to bring a charge under
our current law one of three other
things also needs to happen
the child also has to use the gun in a
reckless or threatening manner
or the child has to discharge the gun in
a reckless or threatening manner or the
child has to commit a felony or a
misdemeanor with it
so basically what we have now here in
New Hampshire is a no harm no foul law
with a maximum penalty of a one thousand
dollar violation
even if a child or another person loses
their life as a result
in New Hampshire data on shootings of
involving young children accessing
unsecured Firearms can be very difficult
to find
this data isn't tracked in any sort of a
centralized database either at the state
level or at the federal level
because these incidents involve
juveniles police and court records are
often sealed and the media is very
reluctant to report them
but these incidents are happening in our
state
a four-year-old boy shot himself in the
hand in 2021 and where
an 11 year old boy in Alton who accessed
a loaded unsecured firearm fatally shot
both of his parents
a ten-year-old boy in a Durham home
filled with unsecured guns and
ammunition fatally shot himself back in
2016.
the Durham case is especially
interesting because the prosecutor chose
not to prosecute the gun owner despite
the fact that the gun the child used to
take his life was unsecured so how could
that be
because our current law only covers
loaded weapons that are unsecured in the
Durham case the unsecured weapon was
unloaded but the ammunition for it was
nearby
needless to say the child was able to
put two and two together with tragic
results
one of the things that this bill will do
is fix that flaw in the law
the bill will also broaden the
circumstances that constitute negligence
so in addition to child a child using or
discharging the gun in a reckless manner
or using it to commit a crime it will
expand the scope of the law to a child
displaying the weapon to others or
bringing the weapon onto the grounds of
a school or any facility public or
private that's accessible to members of
the public where other people are
present
the bill also toughens penalties for an
offense
instead of a violation and a maximum one
thousand dollar fine a negligent gun
owner would be charged with an
unclassified misdemeanor and if the
child discharges the weapon resulting in
the injury or death of the child or
another person that penalty would be
elevated to a class B felony
the penalty also would increase to a
class B felony If the child uses the
weapon in the commission of a felony
here
Bill won't do is compound a tragedy by
charging a parent whose child is killed
or injured with a crime unless the
situation involves gross negligence and
that by the way is exactly how our
current law operates there's nothing in
this bill that actually removes that
particular exemption
so in a state where guns are part of our
culture taking responsibility to protect
our kids from the very real risk that
unsecured Firearms present must also be
part of our culture
HB 351 would encourage this by making it
a stronger part of New Hampshire law
colleagues our choice today is to pass a
bill that would better protect children
who look to adults like us to protect
them
or to allow a small minority of
irresponsible adults to remain virtually
unaccountable for endangering all of New
Hampshire's children
please vote with me and press the green
button for HB 351 and Mr Speaker I ask
for a division vote thank you there's a
member yield the questions
I do not remember it does not yield
representative hole has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 351 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative stone
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that a majority of
New Hampshire citizens are responsible
gun owners
and Mr Speaker if I know that this is
not Massachusetts California Florida or
any other state and it is New Hampshire
Mr Speaker if I know that we have an
industry that provides trigger locks and
other safety devices as mandated by the
federal government already for any
commercial sale of a firearm
Mr Speaker I would now press the red
hold on excuse me
for another motion appropriate motion to
be made
chair recognize representative Ray
if I know that there are very few few
tragedies
greater than the death or injury of a
child
especially when it is a result of
negligent firearm storage
and finally if I know when this bill
becomes law it will never affect
responsible firearm owners
who store their weapons
safely to keep them out of the hands of
children
but currently
those who do not store their firearms
safely only face a violation as
punishment
would I now press the green button
to pass this bill
in Strunk and strengthening the current
law
to at least do something to prevent
these tragedies thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before is ought to pass on
House Bill 351. it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button you'll be opposed press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
ball members president under opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
182 voting yay 203 voting a the auto
pass motion fails what reason member
arise to move in expedient to legislate
on House Bill 351 the whole most
inexperiod to legislate on House Bill
State your motion
Mr Speaker I move
indefinite postponement on House Bill
351.
that motion is in order
division has been requested
the motion before us is indefinitely
postponed on 351. this is a division
vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposed you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
well members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
202 voting yay 183 voting a indefinite
majority committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
house bill 397. act relative the
prohibition of the possession of
hypodermic needles by miners having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass first
representative Terry Roy for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpected to legislate representative
Jonathan stone for the minority of the
committee the question is on the motion
to ought to pass
on House Bill 397. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
committee on education to which was
I would like to remind everyone that
we've still got a lot of work to do
today
and if we steep keep having three to
five minutes to get back into a roll
call or division we're going to be here
quite late tonight
so it's up to you
committee on education to which was
referred cacr7 relating to the use of
money raised by taxation for Education
providing that money raised by taxation
may be applied for the use of religious
educational institution comes with a
without recommendation
of cordelli moves ought to pass chair
cacr7 asks the age-old question
should public taxpayers be made to
devote their publicly collected tax
dollars to Religious Education and
instruction without their authorization
since the Inception the state of New
Hampshire has been opposed to public tax
dollars being devoted to a particular
sect or denomination
our 1784 New Hampshire Constitution part
1 article 6 States quote
but no Persians shall ever be compelled
to pay towards the support of the school
of any sect or denomination end quote
the founders of our
State confirmed that the use of Revenue
raised by taxation for the purpose of
religious education would not stand
so they established the tradition
239 years ago
and made clear that no one should have
to pay for another's religious
instruction
the tradition reflected Thomas
Jefferson's view of the separation of
church and state
in 1802 Jefferson stated that by
adopting the First Amendment to the U.S
Constitution it had quote built a wall
of separation between church and state
even though there is an established
tradition in our state and our
constitution to practice the separation
of church and state Advocates of CR
cacr7 want to repeal the 1877 amendment
to our Constitution which further
instilled the concept that the public
collected tax dollars should not be
allocated to religious institutions
at our Arctic at issue is article 83 of
our Constitution which states quote no
money raised by taxation shall ever be
granted or applied for the use of
schools or institution of any religious
sector or denomination end quote
now this is the blame Amendment
admittedly at the time when Maine
Senator Blaine brought forth this issue
to the U.S Congress it was anti-catholic
and anti-immigrant
even though it reflected the tradition
that no public taxes should go to
sectarian education it was in fact
mean-spirited
however
39 States both at the time and later
later states admitted like Washington
state Alaska and Hawaii adopted the
concept of no funding of religious
schools with public Monies
according to ballot media only two
states have repealed the Blaine
amendment in their constitution
it should be noted that the no Aid
Clause of part 1 article 6 of our
constitution predates the blame
amendment by almost a hundred years
the concept presented in article 83 is
not Antiquated is not outdated it is
fund a fundamental tenet of the
foundation of our state and our nation
now supporters of cacr7 will cite
several U.S Supreme Courts that rule
that public monies could be allocated to
religious institutions
now these decisions were obviously
narrowly drawn they were drawn based on
the focus of deteriorating Cleveland
School District
public grounds to resurface a Lutheran
playground the use of Private Business
profit taxes and the assistance to a
rural School District
most of our con most of our constituents
concur with the Jeffersonian belief that
the in the concept of the separation of
church and state
that guarantees that no tax dollars will
support any religious Institution
I have always felt that the practice of
one's faith is a private personal matter
our ancestors understood this the New
Hampshire Constitution also charges the
state with the responsibility and the
obligation to provide adequate public
education to all New Hampshire students
through their Public Schools it stands
to reason that allocating Public's guns
to private or religious schools without
extenuating circumstances but only
further violate this principle
colleagues I urge you to support our
Constitution and the Jeffersonian
principle of the separation of church
and state by voting no on cacr7 thank
you Mr Speaker and I would call for a
the motion before us has ought to pass
I recognize representative chair
thank you Mr Speaker
chcr7 is a constitutional amendment to
repeal the so-called blame Amendment
from our constitution
this 1877 amendment to our constitution
basically said public funds cannot be
granted to religious schools
this amendment needs to be repealed for
two simple reasons
first
it is a relic of an anti-catholic
anti-religious bigotry of the 1800s
it was placed in our constitution as a
result of that bigotry because public
schools of that era were Protestant
schools and taught from Protestant
Bibles
when Catholics and other immigrants
started arriving in this country and
found that they wanted to have their own
schools and their own religion taught in
those schools
this led to discrimination and violence
in Philadelphia there were Bible riots
on which version of the Bible to be used
in Maine a Catholic Church was burned
and the priest was tarred and feathered
in New Hampshire there were attempts to
burn down churches in Dover and
Manchester and these were not isolated
incidents
an amendment to the United States
Constitution to maintain Protestant
control of schools and deny funding to
Catholic schools was put forward by John
Blaine of Maine who wanted to ride the
anti-catholic bigotry to the United
States presidency
his Amendment
passed the U.S house but was defeated by
one vote in the U.S Senate
but the anti-catholic movement continued
and many blame amendments were added to
state constitutions including our
constitution in 1877 which was modeled
after the federal Amendment
I will add that these anti-catholic and
anti-jewish school efforts continued
into at least the 1920s aided in part by
the Klu Klux Klan which was active in
Maine
second reason that this appeal is
required
the amendment the blame amendment is
unconstitutional there is a long history
of court rulings Supreme Court rulings
on this ASU but I'll just mention too
in June of 2020 the U.S Supreme Court
issued a landmark ruling in favor of Mrs
Espinoza and her other families in
Montana against the Department of
Revenue
there was a tax credit program in use
there and the Department of Revenue said
they could not send their kids to
religious schools because of their blame
Amendment which was very similar to ours
the case went all the way to the Supreme
Court
and they ruled in favor of Mrs Espinoza
you just heard that there were narrow
rulings that's not true
listen to what Justice Alito said if a
state decides to send private education
private funds
to excuse me if a state decides to fund
a private educational institutions it
cannot discriminate against parents who
choose to send their children to
religious schools it cannot discriminate
against them
in Maine school tuitioning similar to
our town tuitioning program here in New
Hampshire
had a case filed in relation to a 1981
law that was passed that said they could
not send their children to religious
schools
to families sued
that case the Carson versus Macon case
went all to the all the way to the
Supreme Court
chief justice wrote in his opinion again
this is not in our ruling as noted a
neutral benefit program in which public
funds flow to religious organizations
through the independent choices of
private benefit recipients does not
offend The Establishment Clause
in relation to that decision Vermont
settled with five lawsuits from parents
who wanted to send their children to
religious schools
to cite our oblane Amendment as a as an
objection to school choice programs and
to exclude religious schools is clearly
unconstitutional
the plain amendment is what is called a
dead letter
it's an unenforceable statute
as recently in 19 as 1980 we the state
of New Hampshire
repealed several obsolete Provisions
from our constitution
Blaine amendments were born of bigotry
religious bigotry is no better than
racial bigotry
New Hampshire needs to repeal this
unconstitutional Amendment now
the plain amendment is a stain on our
constitution
and as the Supreme Court said back in
remember Children Are Not Mere creatures
of the state
as the Supreme Court said in the
Mitchell versus Helms decision
the plain amendments and I quote
were born of bigotry and should be
buried now
today you can help bury our blame
amendment by pressing the green button
the most the motion before us is ought
to pass on cacr7
representative San Antonio has requested
a roll call that is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
foreign
cacr-7 this is a roll call vote
which Eric and eyes representative luno
Mr Speaker
if I realize that separation of church
and state is important to our
Constitution and if I know that cacr7 is
an amendment to the state constitution
to remove language that prohibits the
use of public tax dollars to fund
religious education then would I press
do you recognize resident Pender now for
that removing if I know that cacr7 would
remove a stain of religious bigotry from
the New Hampshire Constitution would I
press the green button
the motion before us is ought to pass in
cacr7 it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button to be oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
the wall members president had an
opportunity to vote
the motion fails lacking the
Three-Fifths
committee on education to which was
referred Hospital 61 relative to
teaching on discrimination in public
schools and discrimination in public
workplaces
this comes to us without recommendation
chair recognizes representative Myler
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to move to
table this motion please it's a proper
motion the motion before us is the table
house bill 61. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it in House Bill 61 is
on education to which was referred House
Bill 204 relative to non-academic
surveys in schools it comes without
recommendation
I recognize the representative Ladd
I'd like to make a motion to Sage motion
like to make a motions table 204 that is
a proper motion the motion before us is
chair recognizes representative Belcher
when
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 204 this is a division vote care
recognizer representative Belcher for a
thank you Mr Speaker I'll keep it simple
if I know that this bill is important
and deserves to be heard when I press
the red button thank you
chair recognize representative Ladd for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much Mr Speaker if I know the house
House Education committee received 93
bills this year and if I know we have 19
bills on this docket of which we want to
table 16 of them and have only three
debates would you support the motion to
table this bill
the motion is the table House Bill 204
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you press the green button if
you're opposed or press the red button
[Music]
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
320 voting yay 61 voting a house bill
we're on the education bills the next
one we have does have a debate
so it's 5 of 12 now we'll take our lunch
now and come back exactly at one o'clock
the clerk has a has a message uh
announcement thank Mr Speaker if you
encountered a mileage kiosk this morning
that was down please be advised they are
they have all been rebooted and
connected so you can sign in for your
mileage at any time today
the committee on education the Western
deferred House Bill 275 local relative
to schools approved for a school tuition
program by a school board comes to us
without recommendation
representative Ladd moves auction
[Music]
representative Ladd moves ought to pass
and offers Amendment
0839h printed in House Records 16 on
page 72. the question is on adoption of
the amendment are you ready for the
question
[Applause]
a division has been requested members
foreign
to be in their seats this is division
mode
members need to be in their seats this
will be a division vote
the doors are closed
you'll have to go back out
all right the question is on Amendment
zero eight three nine H this is a
division vote if you are in favor of
adopting the amendment press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
thanks
and Bradley
[Music]
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
212 in the affirmative 158 in the
negative the amendment is adopted
the question now is on the motion of
ought to pass
representative Chandler is recognized to
speak against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
and this bill pertains to school boards
in towns where the community Public
Schools do not include include a
complete K-12 program and they contract
with other schools to provide an
adequate education for the remaining
grades
the contract establishes the lower
taxpayer-funded tuition payment to the
schools or sometimes there are several
schools that they contract with to
provide the remaining grades in the case
of choices school boards may enter into
different tuition agreements with the
different schools and in some
circumstances School boards have like a
cap on tuition
this bill allows a parent who wishes to
enroll their child in a school whose
tuition cost is more than the local
tuition cap
allows the parents to pay the additional
funds
these parents are often looking for
special academic programs Sports
programs religious training or other
benefits and the bill benefits a few
while potentially affecting many
students in the district
what can and in fact has happened is
that a school board in town for one
reason or another sets a tuition payment
that's low and that payment was lower
than the tuition to the nearby public
school
that was contracted with the town to
provide education in grades they didn't
offer the parents who wanted to continue
to send their children to the public
school which provides all the grades has
Career and Technical education
idea accommodations professionally
licensed Educators co-curricular
activities dual enrollment classes as
well as providing an adequate education
where these parents were in the position
of paying a hefty extra tuition fee that
they could not afford particularly if
they had several kids luckily the town
realized this inequity and supported
full tuition
so I feel this bill has some unintended
consequences and it has a few flaws to
it and certainly the amendment makes it
better it puts into statute the
possibility that a school board in town
could set a tuition payment at a level
that not only allows parents to pay
tuition for these special hype class
schools but it would also Force the
majority of parents to pay for a free
public education for their children or
have homeschooling as an alternative so
it kind of opens up Pandora's box of
budgeting and other issues for school
districts who are on the contract and
puts an added Financial pressure on low
and middle income parents who should not
end up paying for a public school
education for their children so I ask
you to join me in voting itl on this
representative lad is recognized to
speak
the school tuition program is a program
you've had in the books here in the
state for many many years same thing
across the river in Vermont
we have different kinds of
configurations and structures of schools
when we're talking about the tuition
program we have k-5s we have k-4s we
have K through eights and if you don't
have the receiving facility in your own
town for example grades 9 through 12 or
possibly grades 5 through 12. you
tuition them out the school board the
sending School Board must approve the
receiving school as part of the tuition
program
now in the community I live in in
communities which I represent this is
occurring in two communities in landaf
which is a small community which has the
blue school which is approximately
grades K through three roughly around 30
some odd students
they send their kids off there's a
tuition agreements made with three
locations
Lisbon where the majority of kids go and
transportation is provided and all those
Services which were just mentioned are
offered there so every student receives
the opportunity for an adequate
education but they also have two other
schools profile going to the East and
then St Johnsbury Academy to the west
where there's two students taking this
namely because that's where the parent
works
and for in high school we're not
required to provide transportation
that's in our statutory law
so if the parent is driving over to
Franconia to go to profile why not take
your child with you
if you're willing to pay the difference
fortunately in land app they pay that
difference which is a slight difference
now the other community which I'm
talking about is Piermont to myself they
have tuition agreements with five
schools St Johnsbury Academy which is
like a Pinkerton same quality of
Education excellent quality education as
we have most of our Public Schools but
these are Independent Schools Pinkerton
and ncj then we also have agreements
over there with Bradford Vermont which
is Oxbow High School which also has the
CTE Center for all that that side of the
river and our side of the river
then we have Rivendell which is part of
Orford and fairly Vermont so it's an
interstate School District we also have
Thetford Academy which is in Vermont and
Woodsville High School which is in
Haverhill where I live those are all
under tuition agreements that they have
signed in Paramount for their students
have the option to go where they want to
go now they can't go to just any school
it has to be a school approved by the
sending School District
and all those schools I just spoke of re
provide the services
that are required in any of our Public
Schools so there's no discrimination
the issue that occurred in Piermont was
that there were four students that were
thinking about going up to St Johnsbury
Academy they go there because of the
science program they go across the
Bradford because a wonderful theater
program they go up to Haverhill or
Woodsville because we always win the
soccer championship and
for those that are in division four and
they go down to Rivendell because they
also win all the basketball stuff or
they have a wonderful math program down
there
there's reasons why parents to go in
certain directions but what we had is of
those four students that opted to go
wanted to go to Saint J1 during covid
opted to go across the river to Bradford
and didn't have an opportunity to walk
in the school and see it was all done
back then on the web you did this visual
tour and they said oh that's a wonderful
place I'll go there the others went to
Saint Jay because their siblings had
gone there the cost for going to St
Johnsbury Academy was right around the
cap which they had for for Piermont they
make this cap based upon taking the cost
of Woodsville High School
Rivendell and Bradford averaging those
costs and then adding an 18 percent in
top it comes up just shallow of twenty
thousand dollars around nineteen
thousand seven hundred dollars
so that one child who went to
um Bradford after one year said this is
not where I want to go I want to go with
my other three friends who went to Saint
J in the interim Saint Jay added some
cost to their their cap or their tuition
rate to twenty thousand eight hundred
dollars
a few dollars over the cap for that town
so the town says no you can't go to your
above or cap parent says can I pay the
difference in many towns throughout the
state that's permissible because we have
nothing on the books saying you can or
you can't a parent pay the difference
as this legislation is being brought to
you it allows the school board they must
approve the sending school they can make
the decision also if they're going to
allow that parent to pay the difference
or or they will pay the difference that
option is in in the bill
so what we're trying to do is provide
the option for the parent to make a
choice based upon approved schools in
that local sending district and a proven
based upon the needs of that particular
child this has been going on for years
throughout the state we're just trying
to get some clarifying language into
the question is on the motion of octopus
with Amendment
are you ready for the question
this will be a division vote members
foreign
the question is on the motion about to
pass as amended on House Bill 275 this
is a division vote
representative Bell Boney is recognized
no that this bill clearly benefits
wealthier families who can afford to pay
the cost over the tuition cap and harms
families who did not have the means to
do so
and I know that this bill will allow
school boards to lowball the costs for
school tuition or a pod pretending to be
a school
and I know that this would lead parents
with no option other than to pay out of
pocket for tuition to a good school
then would I now press the red button to
provide more equity for lower income
families
representative Ladd is recognized for
thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know that sending school districts
throughout New Hampshire tuition their
students to board approved receiving
schools and districts as part of the
state school tuition program and if I
know this bill clarifies that a parent
who wants to send his or her child to an
approved school where tuition May extend
beyond the cap that the parent May pay
the difference as long as at least one
other tuition option does not require
additional tuition payment from the
pyramid parent and if I know that with
this legislation all children in
ascending district will continue to
receive the opportunity for an adequate
education as prescribed by law and
lastly if I know this legislation change
will better support parents in making
the appropriate choice for their
children would I then press the green
button to move this bill forward thank
you
the questions on the motion of Ocho
passes with amendments on House Bill 275
if you're in this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red button
okay
[Music]
of all members presence have had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
201 in the affirmative 181 and the
Daily News
table
the committee on education which was
referred House Bill 331 FM local
relative to the income threshold for the
education Freedom account program comes
to us without recommendation
for what reason does a member rise in
Motion state your motion I moved it to
House Bill 331 be laid on the table
representative cordelli moves at House
roll calls that's officially seconded
okay that's sufficiently seconded this
close the door we haven't closed the
the question is whether to a house bill
331 on the table
representative hole is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that education matters a lot
if I know that this chamber has
historically had really robust debates
on legislation
if I know that not every parent is happy
with their school system and would like
another option
what I now vote green on the table
motion sorry red on the table motion
representative Ladd is recognized for
parliamentary and green would be
wonderful
Mr Speaker
if I know this bill has a FN on it a
financial note
and if I further know
that the FN bills have already cleared
the station in division two
and on the road to finance so we've
missed it here would I then support the
motion to table by pushing the green
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 331 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
277 in the affirmative 103 on the
negative House Bill 331 is laid on the
table
the committee on education which was
referred to House Bill 371 establishing
a commission to evaluate and recommend
standards for public schools comes to us
without recommendation
for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion to table House Bill 371
representative luno moves at House Bill
371 be laid on the table are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it on House Bill 371 is
foreign
the committee on education which was
referred House Bill 427 relative to
public comments and inquiry during
school board meetings comes to us
representative cord jelly moves ought to
okay for what reason to remember rise
yes Mr Speaker I would move that this
bill be laid on the table
representative cordelli moves at
hospital 427 be laid on the table are
representative Heinz would like a roll
call
is is that sufficiently seconded
it's not a challenge
it's not a challenge this will be a
oh my goodness okay
so the question is whether to lay House
on the table
all right
foreign
House Bill 427 on the table this is a
division vote representative Heinz is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
is about free speech and debate and our
job is to speak and debate would I then
give the bill the the desert direct what
it deserves under the First Amendment
thank you for being disrespectful I
won't Point your name out thank you Mr
Speaker
representative
Miler is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
motion to table is as a result of a
bipartisan effort would I now press the
um
questions whether layhouse Bill 427 on
the table this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red button
yes
representative Leafly
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
309 and the affirmative 72 and the
negative House Bill 427 is laid on the
table
got it
the committee on education which was
referred House Bill 432 FN relative to
participation in the education freedoms
account program comes to us without
recommendation for what reason does a
member rise
make a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion I I move to table this motion
thank you representative Miler moves to
lay House Bill 432 on the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and 432 was laid on the
table
the house clerk is recognized for an
announcement thank you Mr Speaker just a
reminder we have had over the past few
weeks we have had several incidents
where our janitorial staff has had to
clean up the seats and or the floor
under your seats because people have
brought more than water into the chamber
so please if you do not have water in
the chamber and you're drinking from
mugs or other sources please leave those
out in the ante room or not in the
the committee on education which was
referred House Bill 451 relative to the
State Board of Education prohibition on
discrimination comes to us without
recommendation
Mr Mr Speaker I'd like to move that we
table House Bill 451. shocking okay
representative luno moves that house
bill 451 delayed on the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed name
the eyes have it and 451 is laid on the
table
the committee on education which was
referred House Bill 515 relative to
education Freedom accounts comes to us
without recommendations look to the
other side now for what reason does a
member rise my turn
I have a motion to lay this bill on the
table
representative cordelli moves at House
Bill 515 be laid on the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those suppose nay
the eyes have it and 5 15 is laid on the
table
the committee on education which was
repaired house bill 516 FN relative to
freedom of speech and Association at
public institutions of higher education
comes to us without recommendation for
what reason does the member rise
Mr Speaker I'd like to make a motion go
ahead
like to make a motion to table bill 516.
representative papovichi Mueller moves
that house bill 516 be laid on the table
[Music]
representative Heinz is requesting a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
that's sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
okay
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 516 on the table
representative Hines is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
is about free speech and I don't want to
be on record as opposing free speech in
college why then vote no so we can
actually do our job and discuss a Bill
representative is recognized for a
parliamentary incorrect
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that as the prime sponsor for
this bill I've been fighting for free
speech for a long time and I will
continue to do so if I know that the
intent of this motion to late on the
table is to allow certain technicalities
in the bill minor technicalities to be
addressed with the college system and
ranking members of the education
committee on both sides so that we can
get bipartisan support if I know that
the intent of this motion to table is to
allow these bills to hopefully gain
broad bipartisan support in this chamber
would I press the red button to the
green button to support the motion to
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 516 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you are in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
press the red button learning stations
foreign
had an opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
306 in the affirmative 73 and the
negative the House Bill 516 is laid on
committee on education to which was
deferred House Bill 538 FN establishing
a local education Freedom account
program this comes to us without
recommendation
do you recognize the representative
cordelli uh thank you I'd like to make a
motion stage of motion I'd like to lay
representative cordelli moves that
HB 538 be laid on the table there has
been a request for a roll call I didn't
ask for seconds but is that sufficiently
seconded and I guess it is
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
the motion before us delay House Bill
538 on the table this is a
roll call vote
chair recognized representative Manion
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
want the debate on the merits of
allowing
to a popular program according to the
desires of their taxpayers and if I know
the EFA program is wildly successful and
popular and if I know that the bulk of
local property taxes are dedicated to
the insurance quality education for the
children of the towns and cities then I
would push the red button and vote
against the tabling motion
chair recognized representative Ladd for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this is a locally approved
program that will assist students who
are looking for another learning fit
that best meets the students needs
however if I also know there's needed
work to be done in this with some of the
small intricacies in the bill
if I also understand a fiscal note to
complete a thorough committee review was
not provided to the committee or has yet
to be developed and the train has left
the station would it then be best to
table the bill by pressing the green
button
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 538 this roll call vote here in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed to press a red button
foreign
opportunity to vote also attend the
296 83 voting a house go 5 30 days later
committee on education to which rose
deferred House Bill 539 FN related to
relative to vaccination clinics at
schools it comes without recommendation
chair recognize representative Ladd for
a motion yes I'd like to make a motion
stage motion I'd like to table 539 the
House Bill 539 a roll call has been and
forward
against
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 539 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative hole for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I if I know that debating bills is an
important function and just tabling it
will will limit that debate
if I know that there's at least two
cases where children were vaccinated at
schools
without their parents consent and that
this legislation is necessary would I
press the red button to oppose this
recommendation so the bill could be
taken up and debated thank you
do you recognize representative Ladd for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
has some areas where it needs some
improvement as there are smaller
communities with the that has the only
building in town in rural areas of the
state and that's where clinics are
provided if I also know this bill
carries a financial note of which we
received no Financial note
would I press the green button
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 539 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your pulse or press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president under
opportunity to vote I also attend the
257 voting yeah 123 vote in a
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 552 FNA local
relative to making incentive grants for
school districts that improve in certain
assessment scores
chair recognized representative Ladd
yes Mr chair I'd like to make a motion
Mr motion to place this bill on the
table
General ad moves House Bill 552 will be
placed on the table
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye or propose day
you guys have it in House Bill 552 is
enjoy the committee on education to
which was referred House Bill 572 FN
enact relative to eligibility for free
School meals considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senator Muriel hall
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved as
inexpeding to legislate instead of Mike
Belcher for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0904h printed in-house record 16 pages
91. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
that was Paul's name
you guys have it the amendment is
adopted she'll recognize the
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today to speak against HB 572 for
a few simple reasons we've heard
recently that some of these bills came
to us with a fiscal note with no fiscal
note this was one of those bills however
I ran some numbers myself
and I ran them multiple times just to
get a baseline idea of where we were
going to be at
and let me tell you it goes very high so
what this bill actually does is it
increases the
ability of students to get a free lunch
in schools from the current federally
mandated 185 percent of poverty level to
300 percent of poverty level the thing
is the federal government will not
reimburse for anything over 185 percent
that puts that rest of that money on the
New Hampshire taxpayers
now when you increase that to 300
percent you're increasing it well above
the median household income in this
state
it's reasonable to think at that point
you're going to be encompassing the vast
majority of students in our Public
Schools
if a large number of those students
perhaps seventy thousand out of the
potential ninety thousand were to sign
up for this program
we could easily be looking at a nine
figure bill
nine figures 100 million dollars
annually it's a New Hampshire taxpayers
that is a reasonable assumption given
all of the data that we know from this
on top of that
this gets worse not only does the New
Hampshire taxpayer foot the bill
but this remains a federally regulated
program because we remain in the USDA
free and reduced lunch program which
means all this money most of which at
this point will be coming from New
Hampshire taxpayers
it's still going to be regulated by the
federal government they will determine
the nutritional standards they will
determine any curriculum standards that
need to come along with federal dollars
this is the worst of Both Worlds
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker
today I rise in support of HB 572 as
amended
this bill which came out of committee
with bipartisan support is a product of
extensive interim study work that
involved many Community stakeholders
the intent of this bill is twofold
to help support a wider range of low to
Middle income families by raising the
eligibility cap for free School meals to
300 percent of the poverty level
and two to fund the cost of providing
these free School meals through the
existing Federal reimbursement program
combined with a newly considered
supplemental State reimbursement program
kids access to school meals has been
curtailed at a time when many families
continue to struggle with a rising cost
of putting food on the table
HP 572 as amended ensures that our most
vulnerable Children and adolescents
receive at least one and when possible
two nutritious meals per day
when someone says to you oh I'm starving
have you ever thought to yourself no
you're not you're just hungry
hunger
that's what this bill is about
childhood hunger
no child should go hungry because of
circumstances beyond their control
imagine yourself in a situation where
you're being asked to learn a new skill
maybe one that will affect your ability
to do your job
but all you can think about is the fact
that you're hungry
now imagine that some child's reality is
their next meal might be a day away
we're asking kids to be their best
selves under the worst of circumstances
we can do better than this
we must do better than this now
the importance of food in a child's
education is obvious
School meals play a critical role in a
student's attendance well-being and
academic success
a healthy diet can give a child the
energy to think work and play
we heard an administrator testify that
the toughest part of his job as a school
superintendent was having to make the
decision to cancel school
knowing that some kids would not get a
meal that day
HB 572 does not attempt to feed every
child only those whose families who meet
the income eligibility guidelines
at a time when considerable attention
has been given to the state's Surplus
Revenue shouldn't we consider what we
need in addition to what we want
what we need is to end childhood hunger
in New Hampshire and this bill is a
reasonable start
taxpayers provide students with
computers textbooks and internet access
let's do our part to ensure that our
kids have something in their bellies
when using these tools at least during
the school day
the majority of house education is
committed to assisting Granite State
families in reducing food insecurity and
expanding the opportunity to feed those
who need it most
please join me in voting ought to pass
on this amendment on age House Bill 572.
thank you Mr Speaker I recognize
speaker
colleagues I rise today to support house
bill 572.
my career and expertise as a dietitian
makes it so clear that feeding children
is essential to their ability to learn
and succeed
food insecurity distracts from any other
focus a person might have
after breathing being adequately fed is
the most essential component of
well-being
we might like to believe that hunger is
not a New Hampshire issue but we would
be profoundly wrong
hungry children are cognitively impaired
they cannot learn efficiently
hungry children have less mood
regulation and less control of their
behaviors
HB 572 presents a thoroughly researched
carefully developed approach to reducing
childhood hunger that is very cost
effective
regardless of the reasons a family is
not providing adequate nutrition for
their child that child should never be
left hungry
Federal School Meal programs are not
perfect
but they are much more adequate than
they are usually perceived as and they
have improved greatly in the last 10
years
they provide far better nutrition than
what hungry children experience without
School meals
he's joined me in supporting HB 572 to
feed our children no child should ever
be left hungry
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of autopass has amended
on House Bill 572.
our division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
okay
the motion before us is out of the
majority committee report of water
passes amended and House Bill 572 this
is a division vote
I'd like to request a roll call Mr
Speaker
this is a division vote
chair recognized representative Ladd for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
requires each School Board
to make at least one real meal available
without cost to a child that qualifies
based upon a household income less than
or equal to 300 percent of the federal
poverty guidelines and if I know the
department States this bill would
increase costs at the local level for
providing an increased number of meals
at no cost and at the state level for
Staffing and the administration of the
new program if I also know the bill
creates a need for a new uh form of
determining eligibility as the current
process is under USDA would I then press
the red button so an alternative motion
can be brought forward thank you
chair recognized represent of Ellison
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that many
children in our schools are going
through the school day without either
breakfast or lunch because their parents
cannot afford these meals
and Mr Speaker if I believe that as a
state representative I have the
responsibility to help feed our children
will I now push the green button to pass
HB 572 was amended and take a giant step
forward on behalf of hunger kids thank
you Mr Speaker the motion before us
majority committee report of water
passes amended on HB 572 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button it'll be oppose or
press a red button voting stations are
all members president an opportunity to
201 voting 877 voting Aid a committee
what reason a member arrives
for a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion I move that we print the remarks
on the preceding debate in the permanent
Journal
without objection
objection
a division has been called members
questions
the motion before us is the printable
marks on the debate of 572 Hospital 572
will win the permanent Journal this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your oppose
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president under opportunity
you won a 33 voting a 143 voting a marks
committee on education do what's
referred House Bill 573 FNA local
limiting education Freedom account
funding to budgeted amounts comes
chair recognized representative Miler
for a motion thank you thank you Mr
Speaker I moved to lay 573 on the table
the motion is to lay HB 573 on the table
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye as opposed nay the eyes
have it in House Bill 573 is late on the
table
committee on education towards the
referred House Bill 603 FN relative to
Education Service Providers under the
education Freedom accounts program comes
without recommendation chair recognizes
representative luno for a motion
Mr Speaker I'd like to make a motion to
lay House Bill 603 on the table
the motion is delay House Bill 603 on
the table are you ready for the question
all those of you ever say aye
the eyes the eyes have it in House Bill
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 621 FN relative to
funds of the education Freedom accounts
program after termination of a student's
participation responsibilities of the
scholarship organization comes without
recommendations here recognizes
representative Miler for a motion
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to lay a
621 on the table motion is delays House
Bill 621 on the table are you ready for
the question all those of you ever say
aye all those opposed nay
you guys have it in House Bill 621 is
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 629 FN establishing
a student Bill of Rights
chair recognizes the representative luno
for a motion
Mr Speaker I'd like to make a motion to
lay House Bill 629 on the table the
motion is to lay House Bill 629 on the
table are you ready for the question all
those if you ever say aye
2008 the eyes the eyes have it in House
also be in order
committee on the election law to which
was referred House Bill 40 relative to
domicile residency voter registration an
investigation of voter verification
letters relatively
[Music]
relative to the terms resident
representative Lane moves ought to pass
the chair recognizes representative
Berry
um thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to make
a motion
State your motion I would like to motion
to table house bill 40.
I'd like to speak let me speak to my
motion I'm into Pi okay
never mind
the motion before us is the table House
who requested a roll call
your question roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
are you ready for the question yes all
those in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it House Bill 40 is laid
which was referred house bill to all
nine enact relative to the form required
to request an absentee ballot consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution that this index
feeding to legislate Senator Stephen
Kennedy for the committee are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
Paul's nay the eyes have it and
the majority of the committee to an
election law to which is referred House
Bill 255 an act relative to campaign
contributions by limited liability
companies haven't considered the same
report the same the following Amendment
the recommendation that fill out a
password Amendment representative Connie
Lane for the majority of the committee
United minority of the committee have
considered the same thing I normally
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpeding to legislators in the
rossbury from the minority of the
committee
care recognizes representative Lane for
hey this on the table
the motion is to lay House Bill 255 on
the table are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
suppose nay
the eyes have it in House Bill 255 is
table
majority of committee on Election which
was referred house will be in order
to deferred House Bill 316 and act
relative to meetings of Supervisors of
the checklist consider the same report
the same with the following Amendment
and a recommendation to build on a
password Amendment Senator Catherine
Pluto O'Brien for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority of Report with
the Fallen resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate it was an
evangelo Brennan for the minority of the
committee do you recognizer
representative Berry promotion I'd like
to make a motion to table house bill
316.
table House Bill 316. table house motion
is the table House Bill 316. are you
ready for the question all those are
here to say hi hello
the eyes have it in House Bill 316 is
the committee on Election law to which
was referred House Bill 6363
relative to deadlines for candidates
filing for nomination papers the state
general elections it comes without
recommendation chair recognizes
representative Ross for a motion uh yes
Mr Speaker I'd like to table House Bill
363. the motion is the table House Bill
363 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
opposite the eyes have it in House Bill
everybody on Election law to which was
deferred House Bill 460 ofn relative to
eliminating voter identification
exceptions this comes without
recommendation that you recognizes
representative Ross for a motion uh yes
Mr Speaker I would like to uh table
house bill 460. the motion is the table
House Bill 460. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
supposed name
you guys have it in House Bill 460 is
majority of the committee on Election
which was referred House Bill 586 an act
relative to absentee voting due to
absence consider the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass Senator Russell
Muirhead for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislate it's in a Ross
Perry from the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative Lane for
a motion
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to put 580
House Bill 586 on the table the motion
is to table House Bill 586. are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye Mr Paul's name the eyes
have it and House Bill 586 is laid on
foreign
also be in order
committee on environment and agriculture
to which was referred House Bill 56
relative permits for sighting of new
landfills comes without recommendation
Senate Bixby moves ought to pass with
Amendment
zero seven seven two eight printed
in-house record 16.
page 56 a division has been requested
members take their seats on the
amendment
zero seven seven two H Sprint in record
16 page 56. this is a house will be in
order
the question is on the amendment this is
a division vote the chair recognized
representative Davis for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know this amendment was
offered in committee and failed in the
Thai vote
and Mr Speaker if I know that parts of
this amendment are unclear to the
Department of Environmental Services and
to members of our committee and also Mr
Speaker if I know shorter pis are more
favorable than longer ones Mr Speaker
would I then press the red button to
defeat this amendment
do you recognize representative
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this amendment has an
important addition
adding
sand and gravel aquifers to the class of
waters to be protected
and if I know that permeation of soils
with pollutants and leachate can
eventually reach our Vital drinking and
natural
recreational Waters
and if I know that serious contamination
of water has already occurred in places
like East Palestine Ohio Flint Michigan
Fort Bragg North Carolina and even in
our own Merrimack New Hampshire with
pfas as well as other places
and if I know that we can measure guard
and remedy ground contamination movement
with this amendment and bill before it
reaches our water resources
what I therefore now press the green
button to also protect the aquifer water
in this amendment thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is the art of the
amendment zero seven seven two h
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed or press the red button
the ball members president had an
opportunity to vote household attendance
223 voting 855 voting a the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as amended chair
good afternoon Mr Speaker
New Hampshire does not have a landfill
capacity problem
it has a trash problem
it has a very big trash problem
a part of that problem is that the state
of Massachusetts is closing the
availability to its landfills and so
businesses are tracking are Trucking the
trash up to us
so
this bill is going to try to say where
we are going to put the landfills
we've had this bill for four years in my
committee and actually we received more
mail than I had ever received in all my
years here
and I I live in Nashua Southern border
and
I drove up there to
um
to Bethlehem and White Field
so I could see what was going on at
Forest Lake
and we had a constituent meeting in the
middle of Frozen Forest Lake
and what I learned
is
we're the ones who were sent here to
take care of them
there's very small towns
with not a lot of money
and a big corporation that was going to
tell people that we need another yet
another landfill
um
so that they have a place to put their
own trash
are you know from other states we don't
need trash from other states to come
here and we don't need
to have landfills just built where we
don't want them and so I would ask that
you would join me and supporting all the
pr all the residents north of the notch
and vote Yes first bill 56.
do you recognize representative
Creighton
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you colleagues
I rise in opposition to the
ought to pass motion for HB 56. the
committee agreed wholeheartedly
with the importance of protecting our
service and groundwater
there have been extensive studies on how
to clean up and make sure that the
landfills are safe however
during testimony Department of
Environmental Service was adamant
the hb66 would tie their hands with
regard to developing the effective
systems needed to properly monitor
landfills and protect our ground and
surface water
HB 56 applies a one-size-fits-all
solution to a complex problem that
varies from site to site
according to testimony New Hampshire
landfills
are currently safe
there are no landfills currently in the
pipeline for approval of this lengthy
process
we need to protect our water from
potential landfill contamination
but we need to make sure that our
actions are well coordinated and have
the intended consequences
we heard in testimony that something has
to be done
even if it's not exactly right
HB 56 as a case of ready fire aim
it is trying to set standards for
landfills
but they will not have the desired
effect
please join me pressing the red button
to oppose OTP so that another motion can
be made thank you Mr Speaker chair
thank you Mr speaker thank you members
currently the device and Department of
Environmental Services rules set the
minimum distance from a landfill to a
surface water body at 200 feet New
Hampshire landfills annually produce
between 2 million and 50 million gallons
of leachate
which typically contains many toxic
substances including pfas
although required double whiners reduce
the chance of a leak leak the risk of a
leaker spill over the multi-decade
lifetime of a landfill remains
significant
the answer is not better liner
technology choosing the right amp
location is the answer
under HB 56 the minimum distance from a
landfill to a surface water body is
based on how far a leak would travel in
five years
five years provides enough time to
detect and begin to remediate any leak
the amendment provides a very clear
Grandfather Clause written in
consultation with landfill industry
stakeholders that that says this bill
will not limit future expense and
expansions at any currently operating
landfill it's also the case that all
currently operating landfills would meet
the sec-back requirement within this
bill
um
Des was not supportive of this bill
claiming that all aspects of landfill
citing belong in rules because
everything about our Landslide landfill
sighting is so site specific any
limitation in statute would prevent them
from issuing variances they seem to
misunderstand the respective roles of
the legislature and the Departments
we need to be clear our job is to set
principles theirs is to make rules
consistent with the principles
signing landfills where only where they
will not harm groundwater and surface
water is an overriding principle for our
state's economy our tourism and our
health
if a potential landfill site fails this
principle it should not get
consideration
for example a gravel pit that would put
a potential leak within six months of
forest lake and within 12 months of the
amnusic river should never be considered
as a potential landfill site yet
following their citing current sighting
rules Des allowed a company to spend
several years and a lot of money
applying for a permit for that location
the request has been withdrawn but
nothing in Des rules says that can't be
resubmitted
if HB 56 had been enforced at the time
they could have determined with a few
tests that the site was not suitable and
saved a lot of money and effort
putting principles like groundwater and
surface water protection in statute
provides regulatory predictability that
industry needs passing HB 56 will
provide the house position that there
needs to be a clear upfront indicator
for landfill sighting and that strong
protections for our groundwater and
surface water bodies are critical for
our health and our economy as my
colleague from Claremont has said water
[Music]
and Bixby has asked for a division vote
members take your seats this will be a
foreign
pass has amended on House Bill
56. this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Arnold
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know according to
testimony current operating landfills in
Berlin in Rochester and in Bethlehem
would have likely passed the test in the
proposed language in this bill leading
me to believe that current Department of
Environmental Services rules for citing
landfills are presently very successful
and Mr Speaker if I know landfill citing
criteria using
hydrogeologic conditions should be
studied more as to how it can be
correctly incorporated into statute and
lastly Mr Speaker if I know that the
ability to Grant time to be taken off of
the leachate travel time in site
evaluation from five from five years to
three years
is vague and lacks details for the
Department of Environmental Services to
follow then Mr Speaker would I press the
red button so another motion can be
offered
chair recognize representative Simon for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that landfills are
the natural consequence of the very high
standard of living that we enjoy as a
people but Mr Speaker if I know that
landfills come with inherent risks and
that this body on a regular basis has
spoken and said that we don't think that
the current standards protect us enough
and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that if our water sources are
compromised that we have no standard of
living at all would have then press the
green button and OTP this Bill thank you
Mr Speaker
the motion before us is auto pass is
amended announced Bill 56 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
or press a red button voting stations
of all members president an opportunity
to vote also attendance state of the
vote
224 voting a 155 voting a committee
majority of committee on executive
departments and administration to which
enact relative to a declaration of a
state of emergency have been considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
Senator Tony Lucas from the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved as
inexpeding to legislate J.C Grotti for
the minority of the committee chair
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill 127 just grab some profit a
process that already exists in statute
at the calling of the speaker the house
will convene during a state of emergency
and determine whether or not the state
and therefore
I don't believe that we need House Bill
127 because we could already do what
when House Bill 127 is asking us to do
thank you
chair recognize representative Tony
Lucas
thank you Mr Speaker
while it was said about current statute
is correct there is a extremely
important difference
right now if the uh
if the legislature doesn't end up
meeting and have a quorum
um then the state of emergency could
continue indefinitely without the
legislature's involvement and also very
importantly
to end the state of emergency would take
a majority vote of both the house and
the Senate
I mean for every Bill we we work on
today and every Bill we vote on this
session
to become law requires a vote of both
the house and the Senate along with the
thank you
and we're dealing with a much more
important thing for a state of emergency
part one article 37 of our Constitution
states in part in the government of this
government of this state the three
essential Powers thereof to wit the
legislative executive and judicial ought
to be kept as separate from independent
of each other as the nature of a free
government will admit a state of
emergency is a truly extraordinary thing
it is the suspension of this
constitutionally mandated separation of
powers well that may be necessary to
respond quickly to an emergency after
some point in time it is no longer
Justified and the legislature must
resume its constitutionally mandated
task of guiding the way any remaining
problems created by the emergency are
managed that must be an active role not
just standing aside and acquiescing to
whatever the governor chooses to do
the recent emergency brought this statue
to our attention it's the first time
that it's ever been used this bill is
not a referendum on how the recent state
of emergency was handled even if we
believe that the current governor
handled the emergency perfectly we need
to consider the possibility that a
future Governor May respond in a less
appropriate manner
also if the state of emergency does need
to extend beyond 84 days the legislature
should have the governor's back and
actively declare its support of how the
emergency is being handled if there's
opposition to the state of emergency we
should share in the blame or credit of
extending it that is our responsibility
as representatives of our constituents
please join me in pressing the green
button to support the committee
recommendation about to pass and I
the motion before us is the majority
committee report about a pass in House
Bill 127 representative Tony leakeis
requests a roll call sacrificially
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is ought to pass in
house bill 127. this is going to be a
roll call vote chair recognize
representative goalie for parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker
if I can't predict the future and don't
know what the next state of emergency or
pandemic may look like
hey Mr Speaker if I know that that
pandemic or emergency might be big
enough where this house is unable to
meet
in the time frame stated
and Mr Speaker if I know that what we
currently have in statute is sufficient
in stating that
the legislature can terminate the state
then when I press the red button and
keep the statute the way it is thank you
chair recognize your representative
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill does not affect the governor's
Authority or responsibility for our
usual weather-related emergencies up to
84 days
and if I know that is perfectly
appropriate and constitutional to have a
different method for the legislature to
declare an emergency and if I know that
even in covid emergency we managed to
get together and vote honest the state
of emergency within the 84 days would I
not press the green button thank you
emotionally Force majority committee
report of our pass on House Bill 127
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your poster press the red button voting
ball members president opportunity vote
under 93 voting a 185 voting a committee
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
House Bill 228 an act relative to
repealing the commission on demographic
Trends having considered the same report
the same recommendation that the bill
ought to pass from the J.C Grotti for
the committee
chair recognizes representative
Schmidt
thank you Mr Speaker
so
how many of you were even aware that we
have a commission on demographic trends
anybody
well don't feel guilty because we have
lots and lots of committees that study
things a regular basis and so forth and
it's only been in effect for one year
and already we're talking about
repealing it
now we have lots of devices and entities
in our lives that we depend on to
provide us with important information
some of them are things like your gas
gauge
how would you like to drive around with
a car that had a defective gas gauge
so the reality is or your smoke alarm
that's supposed to tell you when the
battery needs replacing
but in this particular in this
particular case
the commission on demographic Trends has
had a problem with achieving a quorum
we kind of live in extraordinary times
don't we where we've had to deal with
lots of unusual situations and the
reality is that
demographics are not insignificant
demographics are kind of like kind of
like gravity
you can deny him you can hide from them
but you can't really Escape them and the
reality is we that the the commission on
demographic Trends is not supposed to
develop all this science that's what we
have universities like UNH which has a
very good
uh scientific department on demographics
but what the what the commission is
supposed to do is it's supposed to
monitor what the situation is and the
science is
and they're supposed to act as our
Clearinghouse our Sentry our monitor
maybe like our gas gauge telling us we
got a situation that we ought to be
paying attention to because
demographic Trends have an impact on our
economy our health care our retirement
system all these kinds of things and the
fact that the commission has had some
problems with the Quorum in year one for
crying out loud under these
extraordinary circumstances is no reason
to abandon it
before it's ever had a chance to really
do what it's supposed to do
so I understand you know I've been here
for 20 years
and so I understand that a 14 to 2 vote
suggests that the committee thought
differently and they did
but frankly
anybody's capable of making a mistake
and in this case the committee majority
made a mistake there's just no two ways
about it if they'd known more about
demography I heard a wonderful lecture
a long time ago from one of the
outstanding
scientists in this field Peter Francis
was now moved off to Pennsylvania
unfortunately
but it was incredibly enlightening we
should have a lecture on the subject
ourselves sometime that we could all
have lunch and listen to somebody that
knows a lot about something that we
should know more about so please don't
throw the baby out with a bath just
because we've under these extraordinary
circumstances it hasn't met that's more
of a failure or leadership than anything
else
let's keep it and and not walk around
with a blindfold on thank you so
remember yielded questions
yeah
I'm remain choir
[Music]
hi so
um to clarify about the um
point about the commission only having
access existed for a year
um that is
if you
um that that is due to a temporary lapse
when it didn't exist so you could
um
would you agree that you could um
count it as having existed for longer if
you include the time from before the
temporary stretch when it was previously
repealed
foreign
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 228 are you ready
for the question
All In
division has been requested members take
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 228.
it's a division vote
chair recognizes representative Smith
if I understand that knowledge is power
and I don't want to go around powerless
would I vote know
by pressing the red button thank you
chair recognize representative Carol
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
commission on demographic Trends has
been unable to be fully staffed due to
not having the people available to serve
and if I also know that the Scholars at
the University of New Hampshire who do
study demographics have kindly provided
a great deal of demographic information
to the legislature and the people of New
Hampshire would I vote Yes to support
the committee and not have us try to
fill this Commission
motion before us is ought to pass the
house bill 228 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button to be opposal press the red
button warning stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
347 voting yay 30 voting a committed
majority committee on executive
departments Administration to which was
referred House Bill 339 FN
prohibiting the investment of State
funds in any company participating in a
boycott of Israel consider the same
report the same in the following
resolution resolve that as in expedient
to legislate the percent Grody for the
majority of the committee an RDA
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
report the recommendation if the bill
ought to pass
representative Kimberly a bear for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
explain for a parliamentary inquiry
I'd like to make a motion
make a motion I apologize I I'd like to
move that HB 339 be laid upon the table
we'll explain moves at HB 339 be laid on
the table you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
supposed
rides have it in House Bill 339 is laid
advising the membership and structure of
the New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs we consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpeding to
Legacy Stacy Grody for the committee
okay I recognize representative growerty
for a
motion
speaker the motion is to lay House Bill
390 on the table are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
Mr post nay
the eyes have it and House Bill 390 is
committee on executive departments
Administration to which was referred
House Bill 461 FN relative to a
millennium elimination by political
subdivision employers of a group 2
retirement position considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendations of all the
password Amendment Senator Matthew Simon
for the committee amendment is zero
seven eight two eight president house
record 16 Pages 86 through 87. the
question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
proposing a you guys have it and the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is not a password Amendment now
you ready for the question all those
people say aye Mr closed nay you guys
have it and the committee report is
adopted
committee on Executive Department's
Administration to which was referred
House Bill 507 FN relative to
unauthorized practice occupational and
professional licensing and certification
it comes without recommendation Gea
recognize representative Simon for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I move we leave HP
507 on the table representative Simon
moves that we lay House Bill 507 on the
table
and it's a very it is sufficiently
seconded
this will be a roll call vote
on the tabling motion members take your
seats
foreign
on the table
this is a roll call vote house will be
in order
care recognizes Senator Testo for a
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
enables voluntary action between
individuals
and if I know that this bill impart
increases Public Safety by removing the
incentive for fraud and if I know that
the market will continue to demand
licensing even without threats of
violence from the state
then when I press the red button so we
can have a debate on this important
topic thank you
do you recognize representative Simon
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill is incredibly
unpopular with constituents if I further
know that members of the committee have
reconsidered their own opinion on the
bill and this bill is almost certainly
going to die anyways and uh furthermore
Mr Speaker if I know that Although our
table is expanding at about at a really
rapid rate we can probably fit one more
bill on it would I move to table this
Bill thank you
the motion before us is table house bill
507. it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button to
reupholster press a red button warning
all members president an opportunity to
308 voting yay 71 voting a house bill
for what reason to memorize uh thank you
Mr Speaker I arise to make a motion
State commotion I move that we um and
I've been told that in a great outbreak
of bipartisanship that if we tried a
special order HP 49 in the morning that
it is likely to pass
so I I move that we special order House
Bill 49 first thing in the morning
[Music]
the most the motion is to special order
House Bill 49 until tomorrow morning and
the house will be in order
all right I wouldn't come up here unless
I was told that this was agreed to
the motion is to lay is to
special order House Bill 49 until
tomorrow morning and the first order of
business are you ready for the question
division has been requested members take
roll call has been asked for is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members take
amazing
the motion before us is the special
order House Bill 49 until tomorrow
morning the first order of business this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
Rock You
all members president an opportunity to
for what reason to memorize I I to ask a
question of the speaker yes okay uh
under Bill HB 572 which was the free
school lunch program it clearly
appropriate State funds so I'm just
trying to understand why under house
rule 47a that's not being referred to
finance and why it was allowed to go to
this point and because the rule
explicitly says it has to go to finance
maybe so why didn't it well I am not
completely familiar with what you're
talking about so
and house rule 47a talks about two
committees
when when we first assigned the bill uh
and if you're asking me to remember why
we didn't send it to finance at that
point maybe we didn't have a financial
statement at that point I I honestly
don't remember okay well I guess my
question is since it clearly is
appropriating money and the rule clearly
says that it's supposed to go to finance
do we have any uh any alternative now
it was not designated as an early bill
and therefore it
it is not required to go to finance so
again I'm not trying to be argumentative
here but if someone makes a mistake and
doesn't designated bill is an early bill
then forever and ever it's not an early
Bill even though the rule clearly says
it should I'm not I don't not saying
anybody made a mistake
we did when we we assigned the bills it
so I don't it talks about spending all
just
committee on Executive Apartments
Administration to which was referred
House Bill 532 FN relative to licensure
and Regulation and music therapists
wrote up moves the moves ought to pass
with the amendment
the amendment is zero four eight o h
printed in-house record 16 Pages 89 88
and 89.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment and all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the motion before us now was ought to
pass as amended the chair recognized
relative to licensure and regulation of
the purpose of Licensing is
not for this purpose this was for
insurance purposes in committee and we
were recommending to
bill
so please press the red button
to vote against relative to licensure
for music therapists
thank you Mr Speaker
let me give you a teeny tiny itty-bitty
course in
your speech is located on the left side
of your brain
music and creativity is on the right
side of the brain
so those individuals who have
brain injuries as a result of a trauma
or a genetic defect
often use music therapy as a way to
communicate to help bridge that
communication gap between one side of
your brain to the other
it's one of those miraculous things that
happens
that we really don't know about or think
about on an everyday basis
music therapists are certified
individuals who attend
up to a master's degree to have this
skill
they help veterans
they help children they help adults who
have sustained severe brain injuries who
have lost their sense of speech they
work with speech pathologists
they are individuals who are certified
in New Hampshire what they don't have is
they don't have licensing which allows
them to get medical reimbursement this
is a very important point in New
Hampshire licensing is the only means
that allows you to get medical
reimbursement whether it be through your
insurance company or through Medicaid so
please
vote for this bill and support our
veterans and those who need
this
I got distracted this service
and doesn't don't have to pay an
the motion the motion before us is ought
to pass
with amendment I a division has been
the motion before us has ought to pass
with Amendment
this is a division vote
chair recognizes Carol McGuire for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
that music therapists are working in New
Hampshire
and if I know that it is not the best
use of our
time and our state resources to create a
separate statute a separate license a
separate Registration Board
separate rules for each
tiny specialization in the therapy field
what I please press the red button
do you recognize your representative
Wilhelm for parliamentary
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire is in the
middle of a mental health crisis and the
need for therapists is
of an urgent need and if I know that
children veterans teenagers seniors
individuals with autism and more could
benefit from additional therapists and
if I know that there are barriers
through the insurance system that
currently exist that if there were
certified music therapists and licensed
music therapists then it would increase
the amount of people that would have
access to care and high quality Care
the motion before us is ought to pass
has amended on House Bill 532 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposed
or press the red button boarding
ball members president an opportunity to
210 voting yay 166 voting May committee
representative McLean declared a
before we get into the next bill
we have procured some snacks and some
fruit that are out in the ante room if
but they need to stay and eat it in the
the committee on Executive Department's
Administration to Richards report at
hci2
enact relative to condemning recent
vandalism and intolerance as recently
leveled against places of worship and
public spaces elected officials and
against the general citizens of New
Hampshire get the cynicism considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislators and of
Kimberly of air for the committee
okay I recognizes representative Maguire
for a motion
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to lay hcr2
the motion before us is to lay hci2 on
the table a division has been called
the motion before us is to table house
hcr2 this is a division vote chair
recognizes Carol McGuire for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
vandalism is already a crime we don't
have to condemn it and if I know that as
a house concurrent resolution
no matter what we do this will not be
accepted by the other body so what I now
quietly lay it on the table press the
green button
motion before us is a table
hci2 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button
your opposer press a red button boarding
Walmart was President an opportunity to
299-49 55 voting a house Bill H HCR 2
majority of committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
deferred HR 11. now house will be in
order
not to relate it relative to welcoming
communities having considered the same
report the same with the Fallen
resolution resolved that is inexped into
legislate so Matthew Simon from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being a no degree
with majority report the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass you know J.C
Grody for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
madraputi
thank you Mr Speaker Namaste my
honorable colleagues and friends
this member will suspend for a minute
the member has a right to be heard if
you need to have a conversation
take it out into the Annie room please
remember may continue
thank you Mr Speaker
I stand before you to urge you and
request you to consider what welcoming
Community is all about this is a house
resolution not like the previous one
which is
concurrent resolution
a similar
resolution which was ATR a couple of
terms ago I've brought it and it was
almost unanimously past the house but
the
Senate did not take it up why do we need
this
welcoming communities nothing but
welcoming immigrants
to into their community and
integrating and celebrating the
diversity
let me give you an example I'm an
immigrant a first generation immigrant I
came to this country with a master's
degree in my pocket and two suitcases
and I made my home
in New Hampshire for over 35 years
and I have seen the diversity what
brought a lot more immigrants was Y2K
many came to help through the transition
and I can speak from
my perspective where people who look
like me who came from India and they
participated and helped through in the
economic investment cultural diversity
and
arts and culture creativity
and today this is 2023
Nashua is one of the first cities in the
Northeast to
officially become a welcoming Community
there is no requirement or a mandate for
anybody to say we are welcoming business
or we are a welcoming City it is just
acknowledging the contribution
of the immigrants coming in to make them
feel like they're participating they're
not an
um a burden to the society
how does welcoming communities
it brings in Workforce
when we are acutely shortage for
Workforce it brings in economic and
opportunities to start small businesses
starting I'll give you an example Indian
Community in Nashua greater Nashua has
over 100 businesses starting from a
salon restaurant to a high-tech company
and a Fortune 500 companies
just one Community
immigrant Community brings in over three
billion dollars in Revenue to Greater
Nashua in one year just one small
community of six percent of the
population in Nashua six percent
just think about it you had lunch today
where we had foods from Dominican
Republic
from
Brazilian Community Indian Community
Nepalese food the diversity of the
palate diversity of culture diversity of
investment diversity of talent pool we
need that
and this is only acknowledging a small
portion
of New Hampshire
that we welcome
do we check the businesses because we
don't have Workforce or would we welcome
immigrants and say hey we'll keep the
businesses going
so I urge you this is not about trying
to change the demographics it's not
about changing what New Hampshire is
it's been a welcoming Community I've
made this home for over 30 years two of
my kids were born and brought up here I
have my grandkid now so this is
something that we acknowledge we are all
human
how do we make this
our state even more vibrant so I ask you
I plead that this is just a resolution I
would love to see a overwhelming support
to this resolution
um
HR 11. Mr Speaker I asked for a division
thank you Mr Speaker and I thank my
honorable colleague for her comments and
I disagree with pretty much nothing that
she said I think the values and the
aspirations that we have as a society
are as a general rule pointing in the
same direction but the very fact that I
can agree with all that and disagree
with whether we should pass hr11 or not
is a perfect illustration of why this
bill is a problem
the bill itself says that it urges that
we as a body are going to urge
subdivisions of the government local
businesses individuals to hold
appropriate celebrations for diversity
throughout the entire month of September
but defining what an appropriate
celebration is and what will be
welcoming to somebody is very difficult
to do
we experience this all of the time down
here different Generations had different
social norms as as they've gone through
their life and some things that we say
in one generation is offensive to the
Next Generation even when we're trying
to be welcoming and accepting of a
certain idea so for example in 20 years
ago
um calling people African Americans was
basically the accepted general practice
it was it was assumed to be the best way
to handle it
this generation it's not it's now people
of color
and some people are offended but you
know I mean we have people from the
Caribbean uh who move here as well
they're not of African descent
um and calling them an African-American
isn't particularly welcoming to them so
we may be trying to be welcoming and at
the same time being alienating
um and and that's the main problem with
this with this legislation when we put
our our backing behind it who gets to
determine what's welcoming the person
doing the welcoming or the person who's
trying to be welcomed in because there's
a lot of conflict that arises and and I
think we all know this there's a lot of
conflict that arises because of this
kind of miscommunication and so the
intent of the bill is good and I would
guess I would just finish with this
um
the title of the bill is compelling and
at the title of a bill is enough to get
you to vote for it then vote for this
bill
the intentions of the sponsor are noble
and the aspiration is good and if that's
enough for you to vote for a bill then
vote for this bill
but if the philosophy that's being put
forward
is not capable of reaching the stated
goal that it's that it's striving for
but instead could actually undermine
reaching that goal then I urge you to
vote for me and vote this itl thank you
has asked for a division vote this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
a roll call has been
it is it is not sufficiently seconded
foreign
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Brian
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that
HR stands for a resolution and not a
house bill
which is sort of like the recommendation
and further if I know that in the city
of Nashua has had a long long history
of a welcoming City we had the English
we had the Irish we had the Greeks the
French and everybody picked up the Rope
and yanked on that rope and pulled and
made a better America for it and if I
further know that most corporations do
branding and in branding is here trying
to sell a product and that's what we're
selling here do you remember like I do
that the old license plates Mr Speaker
used to say welcome to Scenic New
Hampshire
now our license plate says Live Free or
Die then please explain to me how you
can live free and die and don't welcome
Geo recognize representative Carol
have the authority to declare themselves
welcoming communities and celebrate it
however they wish
and if I also know that there's no
consensus on what a welcoming Community
does compared to any other community
and so if I know that it's not clear
what this resolution would accomplish if
anything would I not press the green
button to agree with the committee thank
you
motion before us is the majority
committee report of index meeting to
legislate an H.R 11. this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button your imposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
organizations
well Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 state
185 voting a 177 149 committee report is
adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 50 FN local neck
relative to payment by the state of a
portion of retirement system
contributions of political subdivision
employers having considered the same
report the same the following Amendment
the recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with Amendment
President Dan McGuire for the committee
the amendment is zero nine seven seven
eight printed in house record 16 page
55. the debate is going to be on the
amendment chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker uh Back Again by
popular demand evidently uh
what we have before us on this amendment
is quite different than what was written
in the original bill
the original bill was supposed to be
intended as tax relief
to our constituents
now on this amendment what it will do
will take the money and appropriate it
into the unfunded liability
but ladies and gentlemen of this
esteemed body
the unfunded liability is a moving
Target
they say that it's supposed to be taken
care of by 2039 well go ask that if they
certify that in writing
they won't
it could go a little bit longer and if
the stock market improves it may even be
shorter but they have it on the books to
2039 now the original bill would take
that money and apply it to the cities
and towns we all know the things that we
fought together we forgot we fought
covid we try to get Alternative Learning
I know in Nashua we try to get
computers for the kids and stuff like
that right now a lot of cities and towns
are cash strapped
and by following the original Bill not
the amendment
what will that will free up the money
now
in Nashua that's the sum approximately
almost two million dollars which would
help out
and Mr Speaker also if you remember last
year this body voted
to take this particular bill was one of
the greatest things from my moments in
this house is to convince you all to
support it please do it again
this is really for your constituents for
detect your taxpayers of each of your
community whether you have one crop or
teachers or firefighters involved in
your community what they want is two
things every fire chief every police
chief and the Ever every principal will
tell you is you want to have a good
retention and people that are coming to
work
and by making the benefits better then
you're going to have the people
coming in
this is going to guarantee that so
therefore my good friends I hope that
you will follow me and vote down this
amendment
the amendment will not
satisfy the immediate needs not
something that's attached to 2039 which
is a long way away many legislative
bodies will come in let's give the
taxpayers a break now today they deserve
it
please support me in killing the
I recognize representative Dan Maguire
Mr Speaker excuse me may I have a
division vote on that
chair recognize representative Dan
Maguire
thank you Mr Speaker
the decision you're about to make is not
about whether to spend 50 million
dollars but how to spend 50 million
dollars following this vote however it
goes I will be making a motion to table
this bill so that it can re be reborn as
part of the budget
we have a serious debt problem in the
retirement system
more than half of the money going to the
retirement system is being used to pay
down that debt
so it's greater than 10 percent of all
the salaries of all the public employees
in the state all Municipal teachers
police fires state employees Etc more
than 10 percent of their salaries is
going to pay down debt
this is a huge amount of money if you
think about it if we had no debt all
those employees could be paid 10 percent
more or we could have 10 percent more
employees or we could have money for
so what this bill does is rather than
give employers money for just this
coming biennium
this bill
pays down that debt so that employers
will have lower rates from now until the
debt is retired
because when we give them a dollar today
that's a dollar six we don't have to
give them next year or a dollar fourteen
the year after that or a dollar twenty
the year after that and so on right
because the retirement system expects to
all right so this bill will result as I
said in a savings of a hundred and five
million dollars this amendment will
result in a savings of 105 million
dollars to towns two employers over the
next
um close to two decades
this amendment is supported by the
municipal Association it was unanimously
supported in division one of Finance it
had a very strong vote a bipartisan vote
in the full finance committee
in some sense the original bill is like
a sugary dessert
you know and I understand the
attractions of that believe me
but what the body politic needs is a
nutritionist
nutritional meal not a dessert
so please vote green on this motion
this is going to be a division vote
the motion before us is to adopt
Amendment
0977h this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Vega for
I should read what I wrote down
I can't help you
yeah and you're right
um
okay if I know this amendment changes
yearly direct support which over the
two decades will probably be in the
range total out to be about 600 million
to towns and cities to a one-time
payment against the unfunded accrued
liability of the New Hampshire
Retirement System
if I know this yearly support was
promised by the state when it convinced
the towns cities and counties
to join a Consolidated Retirement System
if I know towns cities and counties
prefer to get yearly direct payments to
help offset the cost of benefits to
police firefighters and teachers instead
of indirect but helpful
and Mr Speaker if I know the towns
cities and counties in their inhabitants
and businesses would greatly appreciate
the yearly support and help to defray
property tax increases
then I will push the red button so
another motion can be made
thank you chair recognize representative
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the best investment of
this 50 million dollars is to return it
to the retirement system to shore up the
unfunded liability
and if I know that the division one
folks a bipartisan group
recommended this
by a unanimous vote
and that the full committee as you see
in the committee report
25 of our members all the members
supported this recommendation of putting
50 million dollars towards the unfunded
liability wouldn't I press the green
button to support the amendment thank
you
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposed or press the red button
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote also attend state of
the question is now on ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
his name
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
see I recognize representative Dan
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
move to table house bill 50 and ask for
motion is the table
parliamentary inquiry Mr Speaker
what
oh I'm sorry
State your inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
I'm a little confused so I'd like to
take the opportunity and ask if you
could explain to the body we just passed
the bill correct
we just passed OTP
okay
we passed the bill but we haven't had
the third reading motion yet
okay could I ask for a division then
the motion before us is to table house
members recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker this is a true parliamentary
inquiry because I this is a very new
procedure for us although it's regular
procedure in the Senate and I'm always a
little suspicious of doing things the
way the body on the other side which I
should not have mentioned does things
uh
if we don't table this bill is there
anything that prohibits it being rolled
no
the motion before us is the table house
do you recognize representative O'Brien
for parliamentary inquiry thank you
uh again popular demand uh if you
believe Mr Speaker if you believe this I
do that the gentleman brought forward a
bill and I think he stated how this was
supposed to be to Panacea yet
comes right back with a motion to table
I don't know if that really you know
so Mr Speaker what should one do I ask
you what I would do is vote down the
motion to table and let's get on with
the debate and keep the uh to Bill alive
thank you Mr Speaker if the intentions
are well intended
okay I recognize representative Dan
Maguire from parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
finance committee could have retained
this bill but we wish to ask this body
what policy they wanted to have how we
wanted to spend this money
and if I know that that policy has now
been decided and if I know that by
tabling this bill it will become part of
the budget and if I know that as part of
the budget it will have that much more
strength in terms of our future
negotiations with the other body
and if I know that if we left it simply
as a bill and passed it over the other
body they could just as easily get rid
of it
as a single bill
would I now push the green button thank
you
the motion before us is to table house
bill 50 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your upholster press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote hustle attend the state of the
vote
206 warning yay 170 voting a HB 50 is
21 finances which referred House Bill
384 FNA net relative to building a new
legislative parking garage making
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment sin of care and evil for the
committee amendment is 0421h printed in
house record 16 pages 76-77
the question is on the amendment all
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye no suppose nay you guys
have it and amendment is adopted the
question before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
another supposed name the eyes the eyes
foreign
House Bill 506 FNA act relative to the
construction of a real Trail box tunnel
on exit 4A in Derry and making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that as
in expedient to legislate representative
chair recognizes representative Stephen
Pearson
good afternoon colleagues
and
okay so here's what we're talking about
in the town of dairy which I represent
the
Department of Transportation is adding
an exit to Interstate 93.
that exit
will come across into
because it's in Londonderry we'll come
across into Dairy and it will cross the
protected historic Railroad Bed that we
have in the town of Derry
there were public hearings that were
done there was designs that were brought
forward
and everything was going along pretty
good and then the Department of
Transportation decided at kind of the
last minute to make a change
and we had to force them to do another
public hearing
which was really done really done at the
and what that did was it removed a box
tunnel underneath a six-lane road on
this exit
which would easily fit into this room
actually it would fit into half of this
room
so that the folks that use the rail
trail system could go underneath rather
than either across a six-lane road or
an alternative design which was a
quarter mile out of the way
under a bridge and next to a flooded a
brook that floods all the time
the important point of this here is that
the Town Council in Derry did not ask
for this change
the Public Works director of dairy sent
a letter to the Department of
Transportation saying I do not want this
change not a single member of the public
asked for this not a single stakeholder
asked for this
the UNH handicap Mobility group said
this redesign is not workable
this redesign puts at a five degree
pitch a 530 foot long
Lane that someone in a wheelchair cannot
Traverse
the Boston office of the EPA has
concerns about this relocation
and the D.O.T has refused to listen to
the people of dairy in its state and the
stakeholders that maintain this rail
trail system
to quote a DOT engineer this is an
integral part of the Statewide trail
system
so if it's an integral part why are you
jacking with it
this will have an effect on Salem
Wyndham Dairy Londonderry and Manchester
this is not a town park this is part of
the larger state recreational concept of
the rail system rail trail system
when a state agency refuses to listen to
the people the only recourse is to bring
that issue to the people's house
and like I said this is part of a
Federal Highway project a project that
received Federal approval with the Box
tunnel in the design and currently now
this project does not have Federal
approval
when this came before the committee
the Department of Transportation sent
someone to argue
as to why they shouldn't do it that
the Department of Transportation wants
to talk about delays in the project this
project started when I was six
years old
and has been delayed 15 times oh by the
way it was delayed six days ago another
six months
so I'm asking you to overturn this itl
so we can tell the Department of
Transportation to please listen to the
and build what's right so that I don't
have to shut the rail trail off in my
community to the folks that are
do you recognized representative Gould
from
thank you Mr Speaker I am feeling good
on the missing Minority Report on hb506
relative to the construction of a rail
trail box tunnel on Exit 4 A
one originally in the finance division
one subcommittee six voted to retain and
two voted to itl on February 15th when
presented to the full finance committee
on March 15 the motion was given that
the vote was itl
second in regard to the majority report
in the calendar saying that the
committee was unwilling to second-guess
D.O.T or to delay the project I would
like to say that there are still
97 properties to be purchased by dots
through eminent domain
uh also the revised environmental impact
have still not been approved for the
proposed New Hampshire dot rail trail
plan alternative
approvals were obtained for the original
plans including the tunnel in 2019.
this tunnel issue is not delaying the
project
the New Hampshire dot alternative is
causing the delay
fourth a key safety point and trail
design is keeping the bike ped traffic
separated from motor traffic
without the tunnel Trail users would be
enticed across six Lanes of traffic
the town of Derry opposes this Crossing
and wants the tunnel
fifth it came to my attention last week
that New Hampshire D.O.T pushed out the
dairy Connector Road Project bid date
from October 2023 this year to March
2024 next year with actual construction
not likely until 2025.
restoring the panel plan will not have a
major impact on the project completion
date
there is only one chance to incorporate
the proper and safe design and the time
is now
it is an issue that people who voted
against the tunnel approach
appropriation perhaps don't understand
completely there are a lot of missing
pieces to this mystery
this project should be approved press
the bread button to oppose the itl
so that the motion of ought to pass can
be given press the red button thank you
thank you Mr Speaker I decided not to
take my chances with that microphone
so
this is a bill came to us in finance
division one we spent many many days on
it more than any other bill that came to
us including the one you just voted on
um and it's it's as you can tell the
advocates for this bill are very very
passionate
but basically what they're asking us to
do is
a sense play civil engineer and tell dot
they don't know their business and they
should do something different
and our committee uh looked into it
looked into all the allegations we
visited the site and let me tell you
about the site the place where this is
going to happen right now does not have
the trail at all so part of the project
is to build this little section of the
trail
the site is a couple of miles away from
I-93 so this is crossing of the
Connector Road into Dairy from this new
exit of I-93
the entire project is now when when the
towns of dairy and Londonderry approve
this project it was in the 50 million
range and when they paid in their
portion that was what it was it is now a
125 million dollar project and probably
yesterday it grew something I don't know
but it's a very expensive project and
this is a little tiny part of it
the place where this Crossing would be
will whether it has a tunnel or not will
have a surface Crossing because it's a
place where there's an intersection
between two roads that intersection has
a traffic light the traffic light has a
crosswalk with a signal with a button
you pushed across
um I personally think that alone is
adequate but in addition to that dot is
designed and is planning to build an
alternative route that goes underneath a
nearby Bridge
you know but but the bottom line is our
committee looked into this we visited it
Etc and
um we voted in our subcommittee
unanimously and in the full finance
committee 22-3
um that that this is not rise to the
level of needing funding
Sam gold has requested a division
foreign
ER
the motion before us is any speed to
legislate in house bill 506. this is a
division vote Sheriff recognize
representative Gould for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that 506
will not delay the exit 4A because there
are many other reasons for it being
delayed and if I know that this tunnel
is the safest solution to the other side
of six Lanes of traffic and if I know
that the criminal penalty will be
removed by amendments and if I know that
this alternative shuts off the rail
trail to our handicapped Community would
I then press the red button to overturn
the Ito so that another motion may be
made thank you do you recognize
representative Wilder for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
was well supported by the finance
committee and if there was very
confusing and contradicting testimony in
the many hours that we spend on it we
finally decided that it was best not to
bring this forward and spend money that
had already been
put in the budget by the Two Towns but I
now support the committee and press the
green button
the motion before us was in experiential
legislative and House Bill 506 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button your opposed will
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
ball members president an opportunity to
300 voting a 72 voting a committee
it is the it is the intention so
everybody will know we are going to go
to six o'clock and stop we are doing
very well so we shouldn't have a problem
finishing up tomorrow in a reasonable
time
for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker to make a motion
please
the majority of the committee on Fish
and Game and Marine Resources to which
is referred House Bill 442 FN
an act preventing State resources from
being used to enforce lobstering
regulations in federal waters and
establishing a scuba diver recreational
Lobster Lobster license
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
Jonathan Smith for the majority of the
committee
for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I was anxious to
get out of my seat for a minute I would
like to make a motion please go ahead I
okay
yep okay representative Harvey moves
that house bill 442 be laid on the table
representative Reed requests a roll call
and that is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
all good
okay
the motion is to lay House Bill 442 on
the table
representative goalies recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know
this bill as amended would create a new
license to allow diving for lobsters but
provides no funding to establish or
administer that license providing an
unfunded mandate and Mr Speaker
if I know New Hampshire
does have a derelict fishing gear and
Coastal cleanup fund
and on April 8th
New Hampshire fishing game in
collaboration with commercial fishermen
but Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
as amended cites the wrong rsas in the
section regard regarding who should be
keeping logs
of locations of these traps it would not
include lobster men to record those
and Mr Speaker finally if I know these
are
just that there are a number of
other flaws in this amendment
and that we shouldn't rely on the Senate
to fix those flaws for us
and that this bill is not ready for
prime time
then Mr Speaker would I press the green
representative Roy's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I was
if I know that I was originally inclined
to support the table motion
and if I further know that after that I
saw evidence of
tens of thousands of lobsters and other
sea creatures dying of starvation
and if you want to know why you're going
to have to hear the bill then would I
maybe hold off for just a few minutes
and let's hear all about this bill
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that I
generally don't care about Lobster and
luster and John butter but this
even a front was an affront to my
conscience I would want to vote to hold
off on the table and hear the Bill thank
you
is
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 442 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
thou shall attendeth state of the vote
131 on the affirmative 245 in the
the question now is on the
committee Amendment
zero seven zero nine H Princeton House
representative goalie is recognized
well I appreciate that members are
taking their conversations to the answer
room maybe start the conversations when
thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues
let me explain that
when we come to our committees and do
our committee work
it's appropriate that especially when
you only have one bill when you send
why am I here speaking against this
amendment
because
there are a number of flaws that should
have been fixed in committee before
going to coming to this floor at least
first of all as stated in my Pi this
creates a new license with no funding
source
second of all
stating that the executive director
scuba divers
with a recreational license may Harvest
lobsters during the established season
but then it goes on to state
all areas outside the zones shall be
restricted to harvesting Lobsters by
so let me ask if it's restricted to just
diverse where are the commercial
we were told
that that shouldn't have been the
language it should have been restricted
from
we should have fixed it in a committee
we use
Town lines and Roads to Mark those
boundaries
there's no markers
what are our Harbor markers but that's
about it
where is fishing game supposed to set up
a Zone
using GPS
we were told divers can't use GPS
underwater
there's no fence to stop them when they
how do you manage it how do you enforce
it
these divers shall abide by the New
there is no guide
this does there's no definition of what
the guide is
this bill goes on to further state that
the location and tracking of
person who holds a license to take
those rsas have nothing to do with
commercial Lobster licenses
that was brought up during the exact
session
here it is still in the bill in the
amendment
and this was a big deal for the fishing
game as well as a commercial lobsterman
it adds into the language for traps that
are attached or retrievable no person
except the owner and then adds or
so instead of the commercial lobsterman
being responsible for his own traps this
now opens the door to say he can allow
anybody out there licensed or unlicensed
to retrieve his traps because he
authorized them to
that's not right that gets strong
we were told well that shouldn't have
been in there
the final line of this is
shall take effect 60 days upon Passage
now those of you who have been here long
enough
no
it is almost impossible
to set up rules and get it through gel
car and set up a whole new program that
so I stand here today and ask you the
stopping the federal government from
enacting stricter regulations on our
industry
that increases more mandates on this
so I ask you to vote down this amendment
I was hoping we could have tabled it so
that a better bill could have been
brought back next year
fixing these problems and we wouldn't be
sending this across the way hoping that
so I'm asking you to vote against the
amendment
do the right thing and
thank you
does a member yield for a question
remember does not yield
representative Spillane is recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
members the original bill was filed at
the request of a group of lobstermen to
offer some protection from the proposed
Federal rules dealing with the right
whales and interaction with lobster gear
and those rules were set aside by the
federal government for an additional six
years making that part of the bill move
the amendment removed the unnecessary
wording but kept the second part of the
original Bill dealing with the sport of
hunting for lobsters bare-handed while
using scuba equipment and free diving
that part of the legislation has easily
passed in this body the last three times
it appeared once on a Voice vote
the amendment does not create a
free-for-all of lobster dive of divers
taking Lobster but it allocates a mere
100 licenses annually
which a diver
using that license may take up to three
lobsters a day
for a season
that will only be about four weeks long
to begin
the amendment also addresses a serious
environmental situation that many states
and countries are now just recognizing
the Connecticut legislature passed a
similar legislation just prior to covid
so you can see we are years late coming
to the game
this environmental situation has to do
with the loss of underwater of modern
steel and plastic lobster traps lobster
traps are no longer things of wood and
string which degrades relatively quickly
in the ocean
the committee heard testimony from the
owner of a Maine not-for-profit company
that specializes in locating identifying
removing and recycling
what are referred to as derelict or
ghost traps from the bottom of the
coastal Waters in Maine
while this company has successfully
removed thousands of these traps already
the estimates are that an additional 3
million traps remain in Maine Waters
imagine for a moment if we learned that
3 million shopping carts were abandoned
throughout the White Mountains
how much of an outcry would there be
but the traps are Underwater All Along
our Shoreline unseen by most people
but there's still a contamination and
they deserve our immediate attention
while we in New Hampshire
have much less Coastline than adjacent
States the problem of the abundance of
ghost traps in our Coastal Waters is
stunning a member has placed a photo
album on the table in the anterum
to show what a single diver with a
30-minute dive at the mouth of the
piscataqua river encountered and
documented
this was done in the week prior to the
Committee hearing
not too long ago and I hope you have had
a chance to look at it
in addition to the polluting aspect of
PVC coated steel traps lost on our
Coastline two-thirds of all these ghost
traps purportedly contain live animals
you'll see in the pictures that are back
there that one has a large cod fish
stock and another one has a lobster
due to our existing laws no person may
touch the lobster trap aside from the
owner
and that is the law even if the Trap Is
Lost
the animals caught in these abandoned
traps will eventually die a slow death
of starvation
even if a scuba diver discovers the
abandoned trap
because it's illegal for the scuba diver
to touch the trap in any way to release
the animal
this amendment allows divers who come
upon gear that is unable to be hauled to
the surface in its present form to
legally release the animals
while at the same time asks them to
record the location for fish and game
both of these parts to the amendment are
important because biologists testifying
said that when the trapped animal dies
the carcass becomes new bait attracting
new victims and the cycle continues over
and over
the committee heard statistics that
commercial lobstermen lose 10 percent of
their traps annually
that figure was disputed by
representatives of the lobster and
Commercial industry but the 10 figure is
generally accepted and backed up in
every study I've read including those
done by our federal government
doing some math with the New Hampshire
Fish and Game statistics of licenses
sold the committee estimates 11 000
traps are lost each year along our
Shoreline
these traps can continue to catch
animals even though they sit at the
bottom of the ocean uncared for because
the Escape panels that are designed to
open after the Trap has been submerged
for about nine months are often blocked
the errant movement of the traps by uh
with tides and storms
covers them up
or it's by the growth of mussels and
seaweed that happens to grow on the
panels in those nine months before the
biodegradable steel ring releases and
these traps become indiscriminate
killing machines trapping mature
lobsters female lobsters with thousands
of eggs undeveloped short lobsters and
other fish and marine species of many
types
the legislation as amended begins a
process of cooperation between
lobstermen fish and game and volunteer
scuba divers to First identify the
location of as many of these traps
and then require the reporting of the
location in a timely fashion to begin
building a database from which we can
work to eventually reach a net zero
ghost trap problem in the New Hampshire
Coastal Waters
please pass the amendment by pushing the
green button
does the member yield for a question I
do
representative Maria dumaine choir
thank you representative for taking my
question would you believe that since we
heard previously that the rsas that were
referenced were the incorrect rsas and
were not commercial uh licenses that I
had OLS double checked their work for me
and they just sent me an email and I'm
happy to share it with the house that
shows every single one of those rsas
references non-commercial software
license non-resident wholesaler license
non-resident commercial saltwater
license and Resident wholesaler license
that they are all the correct rsas
I do
representative Harrington you may
inquire
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you for
taking my question representative there
seemed to be a lot of discussion about
whether fish in the aim could implement
this or Implement that but isn't it true
that every state from Massachusetts to
Florida has allowed scuba diving by
licenses by scuba diving to take
lobsters and that I'm sure our fish and
game department is as capable of the
zozoic come up with the appropriate
regulations
thank you
that is true uh we actually had some
testimony in committee from fish and
game uh disputing or challenging the the
figure that every state along the
Eastern Seaboard with the exception of
Maine and New Hampshire currently allows
scuba diving for lobsters so I actually
personally contacted mass in Rhode
Island
um they both do and we have also
investigated the the game laws and fish
laws all the way down the Seacoast and
every single one of them allows diving
for lobsters however about the Carolinas
it changes from the main lobster to the
spiny Lobster so whether you want to
count scuba diving for spiny Lobster
instead of Maine Lobsters up to you
does a member yield for another question
representative Cahill you may inquire
thank you Mr speaker thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that the ghost lobster traps also pose a
threat to swimmers and Surfers and I
once had to cut free a surfer whose foot
yes I would believe that because the
storms tend to put these things wherever
they feel like it and we've seen actual
balls of these traps as they entangle
one another and become giant mountains
representative Jan Vernon has recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
it should come as no surprise with the
name of Jameson and come from Seabrook
and representing Seabrook and Hampton
I'd be against the amendment
but you also notice if you look at the
original bill that I was a co-sponsor of
the bill so it's very unusual for me to
be against an amendment wouldn't you
think
I'll tell you why I'm against the
amendment
the bill was it was introduced was to
reduce government interference and
government regulation on a very very
regulated industry an industry which my
town was founded upon fishermen
and it was a way to protect them from
government overreach this amendment
takes away that
and adds more re requirements of the
fishermen
and one of the things that is very very
perplexing to me is that it would
require a lobsterman to keep a written
record of where his traps are
oh you know what I've been on a remote
I've thrown Lobster pots over the side
and I also hit my button on my GPS that
told me where I dropped it but you know
what the currents and Tides move those
traps over time but at least I had an
electronic record with it to where to
start looking for that buoy bobbin
but if I had to go back to the port
and download every one of those
Geographic locations and put it onto a
written log that's kind of silly
I also had the honor of serving as a
member of this house
in a commission called the commission
the Coastal Marine natural resources and
environment Commission and I'll tell you
the makeup of that commission there are
two senators and three one two three
four five representatives of this house
on that commission along with New
Hampshire Des Fish and Game
UNH Cooperative Extension New Hampshire
nature conservancy
environmental scientists from unh
yes they have a commercial fisherman
also represented there and two
aquaculture industry experts and our
favorite
state agency called dread
it's very very interesting that that
commission never came to this body with
a recommendation to further restrict
the lobster industry
for uh for
the people that want this amendment to
say that uh a lobsterman doesn't care
about his traps being lost guess what
that's an investment that he's lost in
investment
one two if he throws another Lobster Pot
a string of lobster pots over top of
that derelict gear they get entangled
and guess what now he's out two Lobster
pots for them to say that a lobsterman
doesn't care about his derelict traps is
bunk so I'd ask you to defeat the
amendment so we can move on to the main
Bill thank you Mr Speaker
representative wheelers recognized speak
that's right representative that's right
my friend from Deerfield that is the
lobsters that we're here fighting for
and I think the imagery that
representative Spillane gave us of
millions of shopping carts scattered in
the White Mountains aptly describes the
situation that we are in our oceans
after Decades of the lobster industry
being able to dump these steel cages
into the ecosystem of our oceans sit
littered legislating is about finding
balance between interests and as you
vote on this amendment I asked you to
ask yourself whether a lobster fishing
corporation's bottom line is more
important than the fish getting stuck in
these cages all throughout our Waters
for me that answer is clear our oceans
are more important than the bottom line
our fish our sea life and our ecosystems
are more important important than the
bottom line of an industry
we can't Proclaim to be
environmentalists while supporting
without question an industry which has
not considered the sanctity of our
oceans at all for the years it's been
around
we have an opportunity with this
legislation not to clean everything in
our oceans but to take a real step
forward in getting rid of the millions
of cages that lay in our Waters
join me in protecting our oceans and
holding the lobster industry accountable
for dumping indiscriminately these
killing machines into our oceans Waters
and I ask for your support on the
the question is on the committee
Amendment zero seven zero nine H hold up
a sec
representative Reed requests a roll call
which is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
[Music]
foreign
questions
the question is on the adoption of
amendment 0709 H representative goalie
thank you Mr Speaker
that the establishment of this license
and Mr Speaker if I know
we all agree our oceans need to be
cleaned
but this bill
doesn't do that
and Mr Speaker
it falls short of that I should say
hey Mr Speaker
if I know
that New Hampshire does have
a derelict gear fund
and that the commercial fishermen do do
cleanups on these traps
that fishing game testified that there
are a number of areas in this piece of
legislation that need to be
taken care of and addressed
and it's not ready for prime time
the red button and vote against this
method
representative Jared Sullivan's
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that at 30 percent
fishing industry is the leading source
of trash for the ocean
and further if I know that this
amendment would use proceeds from
selling licenses for divers to go
lobstering and use those proceeds to do
Coastal cleanup efforts and further if I
know that this this law would allow Good
Samaritans to clean up beaches of of
lobster traps that may wash up on shore
which is currently legal in New
Hampshire
and and finally if I know that New
Hampshire despite its Live Free or Die
motto is one of two states the entire
East Coast that does not allow diving
for lobsters would I then vote Yes or
yes and press green buttons so that New
Hampshire can be a bit Freer and also
provide our 18 miles stretch of
Coastline with some resources to keep it
the question is on the adoption of
amendment
0709 H this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor of the amendment press
the green button if you're opposed press
the red button
foreign
of all members president an opportunity
to vote the house will attend to the
271 in the affirmative 105 and the
negative the Amendments adopted
the question is now on ochsa pass with
everybody's might as well stay right
where you are representative Reed
requests a roll call and it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
all right the question is on autopasses
amended on House Bill 442 and this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button if you're opposed press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
okay
[Music]
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
thou shall attended the state of the
vote
276 in the affirmative 100 in the neck
of the in the negative the report is
adopting
the committee on Health Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred to House Bill 69 relative to
direct payments and membership
membership-based Health Care Facilities
comes to us without recommendation
representative McLean moves ought to
pass
member from Hanover representative
Murphy is recognized to speak against
colleagues House Bill 69 exempts
facilities who operate with a
membership-based or direct payment
business model
from the health care licensing
requirement that requires a facility to
adopt a policy to assure that it
provides services to all patients who
require their services regardless of the
source of payment
simply put this means that licensed
facilities like hospitals
must care for all patients even if they
do not have the ability to pay
but the membership-based model does not
it is not a free and fair market
competition model if facilities are not
required to adhere to the same rules of
licensing requirements for the same
services
a Level Playing Field for all is
universally accepted by everyone
in 1986
no less a champion of the free market
President Ronald Reagan recognized quote
Health Care Providers have a societal
obligation end of quote
when when he signed into law the
emergency medical treatment and Labor
Act
the unintended consequences of this bill
would be catastrophic for local
communities patients and hospitals our
hospitals our communities
with already a very tight budget margins
you hear about it all the time in the
Press
hospitals would then be further harmed
by this policy and would potentially
need to pay back Services
Institute a reduction in force I.E
firing people
we're ultimately closed this would
negatively impact local employment and
impede patient access to pay to timely
care in New Hampshire alone we have 26
acute care facilities 26 or 13 of these
are what they call critical access
hospitals some of the very small
Community Hospitals
all these hospitals would be harmed by
this policy if the same day surgeries
laboratory tests studies like MRIs
x-rays CAT scans we're continued
from their day-to-day operations and
performed by those direct payment
facilities who only provide richly
reimbursed services for those with
resources to pay for them
it would create a two-tiered Healthcare
System placing an undue burden on the
Community Hospitals that attempt to
maintain needed and much much broader
service lines for their communities
hospitals must accept patients as
required by their licensing regardless
of the patient's insurance coverage or
ability to pay
if this bill were to pass our local
Community Hospitals would be left to
provide all the well less reimburse
Services while still maintaining a
comprehensive 20 24 7 care to all
patients regardless of ability to pay
clear
with this bill the membership-based
model facilities would not be required
to adhere to the same licensing
requirements and would not offer any
charity care for the same services
totally unfair
House Bill 69 would further compromise
your local Community Hospitals if their
Workforce is siphoned away to work at
these specialized facilities which can
offer more attractive schedules and
higher compensation
as Workforce is the number one issue
facing all Health Care Facilities in
this state this would be unfair and
unacceptable lastly
any payments made to these facilities
would not count towards their
deductibles in their insurance premiums
which will only make any further or
future
more Specialized Hospital
or multi-disciplinary Services more
costly to the patients on an annual
basis and believe me they will need them
in the future
hopefully these hospitals will still be
maintained and still open
this bill fails to recognize the
interconnectedness of the New Hampshire
Health Care system and by exempting the
membership-based facilities from
appropriate and equal licensure
requirements and allowing them to cherry
pick only those highly reimbursed
Services while leaving the community and
tertiary care hospitals to cover the
rest
will only further burden the taxpayers
and the insured
licensed facilities that contract with
Medicare Medicaid or private insurance
and who serve the entire Community
should be protected from facilities that
discriminate
by selecting their patient population
according to their ability to pay
differential treatment of these
facilities and hospitals that provide
the same Services is simply unfair it
creates a two-tiered system and will
compromise our health care in New
Hampshire I urge you all and I I hope
that you all vote no on the auto pass
remember from Manchester representative
McLean's recognized to speak in support
yeah thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
hb69 simply takes a direct pay model
passed into law by this body two years
ago for Primary Health Care and expands
it to Health Care Facilities
supporters of the bill like me believe
that it would open up the HealthCare
Marketplace just a tiny crack to expand
pricing transparency choice and
competition
like the direct Primary Care model
already in use the bill will grant those
facilities and exclusively receive
payment directly from the patient the
ability to opt out of the all-payer
model are currently required in state
law because of this those facilities are
choose to operate under this model will
be completely upfront with their pricing
and they may be extremely attractive to
those patients who are self-insured or
uninsured right just imagine how awesome
it would be to be able to go in for a
colonoscopy or a hernia surgery
and no to the dollar how much you're
going to have to pay up front if you're
self-insured on a tight budget trying to
make the best decisions you can with the
resources you have it would be great if
you could go to a place where you could
escape the Byzantine Billing System of
the current system
last year I went into the hospital for
covid and I received excellent care but
over a year later I'm still getting
bills
hb69 may also serve to attract providers
to the state who might find that it
relieves them of the costly
administrative overhead of the all-payer
model the bottom line is hb69 is about
choice and competition but I want to
address some of the concerns opponents
of the bill say it's going to lead to
Patient cherry picking they say hey
because it's so transparent the model is
going to lure away the best high-paying
customers and it's going to leave
hospitals and other facilities with
lower paying customers like those on
Medicaid
but that that's part of the Bill's
intention and it's not a done deal that
the hospitals are going to lose in that
fight okay the hospitals are going to be
free to compete for every single one of
those patients and indeed they have a
lot to offer those patients as I
mentioned they have excellent care and
most folks with employer-based insurance
are still going to choose them over a
facility where they have to pay
everything out of their own pocket
however
if the hospitals want to retain a high
capture rate they're going to be forced
to look at their business model and the
pricing and billing practices and that's
a good thing opponents are going to say
that you know the bill could bankrupt
the state's critical access hospitals
and got access to care in the rural
regions of the state but the reality is
this all of the federal protections
granted to critical access hospitals by
the balanced budget Act of 1997 remain
intact as does the 15-mile exclusion
Zone defined an RSA 151 colon 4. so when
you lay these exclusion zones over each
other the fact of the matter is the only
part of the state that remains open to
the introduction of the type of facility
brought forth in hb69 is in the extreme
Southeastern corner of the state but the
fact is that since the federal
protections for critical access
hospitals went into law in 1997 about
200 of the country's 800 critical access
hospitals have gone bankrupt that's 25
percent so if you're counting on the
existing regulations to save you it's
not going to happen and in fact in in
the executive session in the committee
we talked about the fact that 70
obstetrics departments have closed down
across the country was that because of
bills like HP 69 and if hb69 and bills
like it were not to pass does that
magically mean that all these
departments and services are going to
come back no they're not the truth is
the current operating model is
non-sustainable and our Health Care
system is on a Glide path to implosion
if we don't innovate in October 2020
Lakes Region General Hospital filed for
bankruptcy at issue was not HB 69 hb69
did not exist at issue was the fact that
they had made some decisions that were
in hindsight unwise and they still might
have pulled through except for the fact
that their operating structure was such
that they were losing millions of
dollars a year and as a result they
never realistically had any chance for
recovery and if things don't change they
won't be alone in the future
opponents say that hb69 would allow
certain facilities not to play by the
rules but my friends what I'm submitting
to you now is that the rules are the
problem the rules are a large part of
the reason that this state in spite of
its ever-growing population has not had
a new hospital in over 30 years finally
let's just contrast the way that we look
at health care and the way we look at
renewable energy on the renewable energy
front we enacted regulations like the
renewable portfolio standard so that we
could explore all forms of renewable
energy and find out what's right for New
Hampshire what's the bet best fit for
New Hampshire
in contrast in health care it's just the
opposite our health care regulations
kill Innovation and they force everyone
into one unsustainable model that
everyone can see is ultimately doomed to
fail hb69 isn't the problem it's part of
is on the motion of ought to pass on
House Bill 69 representative Santo
nastazo requests a roll call and it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members please take your
seats
foreign
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 69 representative
Murphy is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the prior
arguments you just heard only further
reinforce many of my comments and
concerns but that today alone we are not
going to change the entire Health Care
System broadly speaking and that this
bill would simply hurt
Our Community Hospitals and the care
that we receive 24 7 from those
facilities if I also know that as
President Ronald Reagan once said that
Health Care Providers have a societal
obligation and that the proposed
licensure exemption for these
member-based facilities means that they
are not obligated to care for all
patients regardless of ability to pay
and if I know that this bill would place
an undue burden a significant undue
burden on the New Hampshire hospitals
that are already stressed
and that maintain the many needed
Services the many needed broad services
that we all require 24 7 while adhering
to their charity care policies as
required by their licensure
and finally if I know that this bill
fails to recognize the
interconnectedness of the Health Care
system in New Hampshire and will further
burden taxpayers and those insured what
I now read push the red button uh on the
motion uh ought to pass thank you
representative kofos recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the restrictions that
this bill attempts to roll back have
been in place only since 2016.
and further if I know that critical
access hospitals existed before 2016.
and they will continue to be protected
if this bill passes
furthermore if I know that Innovative
facilities that this bill would unleash
are unlikely to be opened in sparsely
populated rural areas
and if I know that protectionism
disincentivizes
Innovation and harms patients would I
then press the green button to pass this
Bill thank you Mr Speaker
the questions on the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 69 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
red the green button
that's why we do parliamentary inquiries
if you're in favor press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
190 in the affirmative 189 and the
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker having voting on the prevailing
side I move reconsideration and I ask
representative Hall moves
reconsideration
this will be a division vote members
[Music]
okay
the motion is reconsideration on House
Bill 69 this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red button
foreign
[Music]
members present I had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
194 in the affirmative 185 and the
we are now back to the motion of ought
are you ready for the question
for what reason does a member us
for emotion
include state in motion
I moved to lay a house bill 69 on the
table
representative Weber moves that house
bill 69 be laid on the table
this will be a division vote members
State you know
representative Kellum across the Roll
Call
and it is sufficiently seconded this
is
okay
the motion is to lay House Bill 69 on
the table representative Weber is
speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
presents a real threat to our community
access hospitals which are hanging by a
thread
and if I know that this body is confused
enough by this bill that they made two
very conflicting votes one right after
the other
would I now vote to place this bill on
the table by pressing the green button
representative Sweeney is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that now is
an opportunity for us to take a nice
calm breath and if I know that this body
has already endorsed the legislation and
the policy of the underlying Bill and
would like to maybe take another vote on
the ought to pass motion would I now
vote red to table so another motion can
the question whether to lay House Bill
69 on the table this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red button
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
I also attended the state of the vote
192 in the affirmative 187 and the
negative House Bill 69 is laid on the
table
[Music]
I don't know why I feel like a pitcher
and the manager just walked out to the
mountain
[Music]
we joined the committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly fast Richard
house bill 114.
an act relative to age at which a minor
may receive mental health treatment
without parental consent having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation of the bill ought to
pass Ms Joe Shapiro for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being an unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to lay on uh to legislate
represent America lay on for the
minority of the committee
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in opposition to the ought to
pass motion on hb-114
this bill would prohibit would permit
minor children to consent to
psychotherapy without the consent of
their parents
this is not the first iteration of this
bill
previous sponsors of this same bill
disclosed in testimony in committee that
this is just the first step in removing
the rights of parents to oversee their
child's mental health care and the goal
is to get the age down to 20 12.
we need to stop this right here right
now
the erosion of a parent's right to
provide for their children's well-being
to be informed of what is happening in
their lives and to be involved in
resolving mental health issues is a sign
that our society is failing families
families are the backbone of society the
member will suspend it is awful awful
noisy in here the member has a right to
be heard again if you need to have a
conversation take it out into the Annie
room
thank you Mr Speaker
families are the backbone of society and
there are currently many forces trying
to drive a wedge between children and
their parents
this is a common tactic of totalitarian
regimes of the past and we should not
accept any incrementalist legislation
towards stripping parents of their
natural right to direct the upbringing
of their children
furthermore Mr Speaker this bill does
not address the issue presented about
who pays for the mental health treatment
children do not routinely manage their
own medical bills unless they are
emancipated minors
if the children are under their parents
health insurance plans then as the
payers the parents have a vested
interest in what health services their
children are receiving beyond the innate
desire and Duty they have to ensure
their children are happy and healthy
this bill does not deal with that
conflict whatsoever
most of you know that I'm a registered
nurse in general it is understood that
miners under the age of 18 cannot
consent to Medical Care
they can assent But ultimately consent
is still required to be obtained from
their parent or Guardian Mental Health
Care is no different
Mr Speaker parents are assumed under
common law to act in the best interest
of their children they have the maturity
and wisdom to help guide their children
in navigating the trials and
tribulations of life
how can they do that if we legislators
create a structure
that for children to hide things from
their parents
there is nothing wrong with a child
going to a therapist and having a safe
space to talk about their feelings and
but the parents should also be involved
they shouldn't be kept in the dark if
there are concerns about abuse we have
procedures for reporting and
investigating
and with due process the rights of
parents can be suspended and then
children may attain Mental Health Care
without their consent
but without proof that there is some
compelling reason
to take the rights of parents away
they should maintain that right to
direct the care for the well-being of
their children
we should not give this even one inch
parents have the right to know what is
going on with their children and the
state legislature should not be creating
wedges in families and taking away
parental rights without due process
period
thank you Mr Speaker
I stand before you today to speak in
favor of House Bill 114 a bill that will
allow anyone 16 years or older to
consent to mental health treatment
this is a short and simple bill it does
not address payment
it does not require a mental health
practitioner to provide services to
minors
it explicitly disallows the prescribing
of medication without parental consent
it does not create an authoritarian
regime
it simply says that a mature minor 16
years and older can participate in
counseling with a willing licensed
provider without the consent of their
parent or Guardian
in fact this bill would clarify and
perhaps limit the age at which a minor
can obtain services without parent
parent consent
current New Hampshire law provides that
quote any person quote can apply for
not a radical idea currently 31 states
have Provisions expanding Mental Health
Services to minors there are many
reasons for this
While most adolescents have caring
competent and responsible parents to
guide and care for them some do not
ravaged by poverty addiction mental
illness or intergenerational trauma
some parents are simply unable to
respond to the needs of their children
some adolescents are in fact homeless
and fending for themselves
in New Hampshire suicide is the second
leading cause of death among individuals
10 to 24 years of age
and suicidal ideation and behavior is
especially prominent among lgbtq youth
the parents of immigrant adolescents May
view mental health treatment as a
foreign idea
and or be fearful of giving consent to
those in authority
finally a maturing 16 or 17 year old in
the process of developing their own
adult identity
we call that individuation
made simply not be ready to share their
particular struggle with their parents
and in fact a skilled provider will be
able to help them speak with their
parents when they are ready and when
they are able
as legislators we are often called upon
to assess the relative benefits and
consequences of doing something
or not doing something
voting for or against the bill that
comes before us
if we do not pass this bill some
deserving youth will go without much
needed care
if we do pass this bill
we might in some
some way limit a parent's very important
role in their child's life
to this I would say to you
please trust that the vast majority of
New Hampshire parents are compassionate
and competent that they absolutely want
the best for their children this change
will not diminish those strong bonds
however for those youth lacking capable
parents or in situations where there is
a temporary breach
counseling will make a world of
difference
please join me in supporting the
majority recommendation of ought to pass
on House Bill 114 by pushing the green
button and I would ask for a division
vote
the division vote has been requested
the motion before us the majority
committee report of water pass and House
Bill 114 this is a division vote
care recognizes senator pelosov for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that parents need to be
informed to be the best Guardians for
their kids
and if I know that the right to consent
to Medical Psychiatric Services is
specifically listed under limited
emancipation RSA recently passed by this
body
and if I know that all other concerns
are addressed by Child Protective
Services would I press the red button to
defeat the OTP so a better motion could
be made
do you recognize representative Shapiro
if I know that a small percentage of
adolescents do not have parents who are
capable or available to assist them
and if I know that a relationship with a
strong caring competent mental health
practitioner Can Open the Eyes of a
depressed and suicidal minor to a future
worth living
and Mr Speaker if I believe that the
great majority of New Hampshire parents
have positive strong relationships with
their teenage children and that
permission for the needy few to seek
help will in no way weaken those strong
family bonds
would I push the green button and
support the majority recommendation of
ought to pass on House Bill 114 thank
you
motion before his majority committee
report of ought to pass and House Bill
114 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed or press the red button
[Music]
four members president and Rob tuning
191 voting a 186 voting a committee
report is adopted
Mr Speaker
reason to memorize having voted on the
prevailing side I'd like to move
reconsideration and urge the body to
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a role called consider roll call on the
the motion before us is reconsideration
and house bill 114. this is going to be
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed will press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
188 boarding a 191 voting a
for
majority of committee on Health and
Human Services elderly Fiesta which was
referred House Bill 238 enact relative
to the role of quality control and
developmental disability service system
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
recommendations that bill ought to pass
with Amendment and Joe Shapiro for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment a recommendation
Bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator William Cushman from the
minority in the committee
majority committee amendment is
0841h printed in-house record 16 Pages
66 through 68. the question is on the
majority Amendment you ready for the
the eyes have it the majority amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question
a division has been requested members
should still be in their seats
the motion before us now is auto pass
with Amendment this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
well Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 the
362 voting yay 13 voting Aid committee
the committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly afastia which was
referred House Bill 299 FN enact
prohibiting discrimination and Medical
Care have been considered the same
report the same the following resolution
result that is inexpedient to legislate
Senator Lucy Weber from the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
from Senator Erica lay on for the
minority of the committee
for what reason to memorize to make a
motion Mr Speaker I moved to table house
bill 299.
the motion is the table house bill 299.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
your eyes have it and H House Bill 299
majority of committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was deferred House Bill 342 FN
enact relative to lead testing in
children having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment and Francis Nutter
Upham for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislate it's in a bill
came for the minority of the committee
the amendment is zero
842h printed in house record 16 Pages
74-75 question is on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye those opposed nay
the eyes have it and amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment which I
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker and esteemed colleagues today
I Rise to oppose itl on HB 342.
my experience in the state house and
working with both parties has led me to
the following conclusion
we rarely disagree on the principle of a
bill and we often disagree on the
solution
HP 342 is an example of how we agree and
yet disagree
HB 342 requires all children to be
tested for blood level lead levels
before their first entry into school and
if not tested before this time will be
given six months to remedy the
deficiency
I hope we all agree our children are
important to us enough to watch out for
their General Health we also know lead
and children's blood affects their
learning ability
it is also known that if a child is
found to have lead levels exceeding five
micrograms per deciliter there are ways
to reduce these Levels by changing a
child's diet
so testing can be a good thing
however let's look at what happens when
a child is found to have blood levels
lead levels more than five micrograms
per deciliter
we have a constituent in Hillsborough
County where the five with with
five-year-old twin boys one tested 7.5
and the other tested 9.5
they are now on a diet and the parents
parents are confident the lead levels
will be reversed in that end time
that's good news right
not so fast
those results were reported to the state
and then their land where landlord was
contacted the landlord now facing a lead
abatement of a typical income property
in New Hampshire
one of the states with the oldest
housing inventories in the nation
decided to handle the case by issuing
the family unnoticed to vacate
to the landlord's credit he investigated
grants to help him pay for the lead
abatement and found one
but the family makes too much money and
did not qualify to return to the to the
dwelling after the abatement
the family is now looking for new
housing in a tight rental real estate
market
this search will displace the family and
will likely result in relocating the kid
their kids in a new school district
the intent of this bill as good as it
might be has unintentional consequences
families displaced housing shut down
while being led abated higher property
insurance costs potential loss of
property insurance and expensive lead
abatement Renovations all this will
result in higher costs to the renter as
well as reduce the number of rentals
available to families with children
under the age of six
we agree light is bad
we need to address the root cause by
eliminating lead from our housing day
care centers preschools kids toys copper
pipe joints and even those old CRTs
the CRT screens
we may still have around our house
we need a solution for all our
constituents and more testing is not the
answer
I've located a group currently working
with landlords on this problem
has made strides in reducing lead in
homes and would encourage you to seek me
to work on Solutions addressing the
underlying problem
please support me with test list and get
the let out by selecting the red button
to vote against to pass as amended so
another motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker
which I recognizes representative Nutter
Upham
New Hampshire is beautiful
I find the most beautiful I find it the
most beautiful in the winter when I
drive her back roads in the evenings
drive through the towns covered in snow
and see the holiday lights twinkling in
the windows I think it looks magical
but beneath those twinkling candles in
the windows lies a silent and unseen
danger lead
lead in the paint that painted those
window sills and walls and woodwork
New Hampshire has the oldest housing
stock in the United States
63 percent of our houses were built
before 1978.
1978 was the year lead paint was
outlawed
the most common source of lead exposure
comes from lead dust that is Created
from the friction of painted service
surfaces such as the opening and closing
of Windows and Doors
testing the blood of children as part of
their physicals has been a way to ensure
no lead exposure has taken place
lead poisoning in children can cause a
myriad of serious health problems even
low levels
of exposure can negatively affect a
child's ability to learn and cause
neurological damage
during the last few years because of the
pandemic and because of the recall of
the easy lead testing equipment that the
doctor's office has had the testing of
New Hampshire children for lead
poisoning has fallen substantially this
is a public health concern for our
children and our grandchildren
House Bill
342 as amended on page 74 of our
calendars asks that the lead test
results be added to a child's physical
exam an exam that is required to enter
School lead tests were already required
at a child's first birthday and in their
second year but this
so having this test done at least once
during a child's first six years we
catch the problem
parents who object to this test can opt
out
the school or the daycare will then
document
and provide the family with written or
electronic educational materials
provided by the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services on the
dangers of lead poisoning and the
importance of blood
lead level testing for children
all the records will be kept
confidential
please join me in voting for this gentle
nudge of a bill
to increase lead testing in our beloved
New Hampshire children by pushing the
the majority the majority were the
motion before its majority committed
report of autopass has amended on House
my mistake you we'll remember yield the
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question
since it's a fact that let ingestion
causes cognitive impairment of children
would you expect that detection and
treatment would save our state and
taxpayers tens of millions of dollars in
special education costs we spend to
I'm sorry I don't have those statistics
with me but I did indeed read that so
yes
a division has been requested members
foreign
pass has amended on House Bill 342.
this is a division vote
chair recognized representative Leon for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that children are already required
by law to be tested for lead before age
six
and if I know that recent low testing
rates were due to the recall of the lead
testing machines
and if I know that linking lead testing
to entry into child care and schools has
the potential to flood new
investigations when paperwork is due all
at the same time
and if I know that we have a shortage of
both child care and family-friendly
housing and that taking those under
investigation out of the market all at
the same time could have a catastrophic
impacts for our families and for those
who rely upon them
would I then press the red button to say
that I do want to get the red lead out
but this is not the right way thank you
Mr Speaker
care recognizes representative Nutter
Upland for a parliamentary inquiry
firemen but that daycares in schools can
now distribute materials to parents
without any penalties and if I know that
passing this bill will help increase
lead testing would I now push the green
button and help keep our New Hampshire
children safe
the motion before us the majority
committee report about a pass and
amended on House Bill 342 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposed
you'll press a red button the boarding
foreign
[Music]
had an opportunity to vote I also attend
193 voting a 180 voting May the
chair recognize the member from Auburn
representative Osborne for the third
Maggie resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only then all
bills ordered a third reading we read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and they'd be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Thursday March 23rd
questions on a third reading motion are
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
opposed nay the eyes have it the motion
is adopted
representative Osmond moved that the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills and Road Bill
amendments and Road Bill reports vacate
motions and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house is in
recess until Thursday March 23rd at 9 00
A.M